Ups, meine Maus geht auf dem anderen Bildschirm nicht. Das muss ich fixen, sonst kann ich Chat nicht angucken.
Chat, wo ist der Chat? Chat ist nicht da. Chat not hot. Chat geht.
Moin, Leute. Bisschen später heute. Lautstärke okay so.
Ich würde sagen, wir spielen jetzt erstmal 1-2 Runden und dann poste ich überall, dass ich am Start bin.
Jetzt bin ich wieder eingespielt.
Naja, was willst du denn großartig einspielen?
Naja, so ein bisschen.
Ja, jetzt muss ich einspielen.
Naja, komm. Also, ich meine, es kann nicht jeder Rechtsklick in dem richtigen Intervall drücken.
Also, du brauchst schon so ein gewisser, also ich muss ganz ehrlich, also jetzt mach mal hier nicht, zieh das mal nicht ins Lächerliche, ja?
Die jutschen Mercy Plays.
So, ich bin weich.
Fertig.
Naja, ich muss erst mal ankommen.
Zieh erst Mercy lächerlich machen und nicht mal on sein. Das ist schon eine schlimme Kombination.
Bann. Instant. Ich sehe keine Viewer. Warum sehe ich keine Viewer?
Da fuck, was ist hier los? Jetzt sehe ich Viewer. Null Viewer haben wir angeblich.
Was sich nicht damit deckt, dass im Chat jemand was schreibt.
So, ich glaube, jetzt geht alles.
Moin, fehlt er nicht. Ich wollte gerade sagen Felix. Nein, es ist Felit.
Felit.
Und I genie Opossum TS mit dem richtig 1337 Turbo Icon anstatt dem Prime Icon.
Nur die Pros haben das Turbo Icon.
Und ja, ich weiß, dass man das umstellen kann.
A little Samsung ist auch da. Moin.
Wer soll ich sonst noch so online bei Overwatch? Mal schauen.
Nicht so viel, wie es aussieht.
Top, da guckt er.
Kriegen jetzt bestimmt wieder Top und Symmetra Mains.
Ich habe Wasser auf die Tastatur geschüttet.
Zumindest nicht in die Tastatur, sondern nur unten auf die Tastatur.
Bäh.
Loh.
Habt ihr eigentlich schon gelesen, dass es sehr wahrscheinlich nicht Bad Company 3 ist, was als nächstes Battlefield kommt?
Was mich enttäuscht, ehrlich gesagt.
Anscheinend kommt Bad Company 3 erstes Jahr danach.
Und anscheinend kommt...
...wohl stattdessen ein Battlefield im Zweiten Weltkrieg, wo ich mal überhaupt keinen Bock drauf habe.
Was mich so absolut nicht juckt.
So on?
Mhm.
Oh nein, nein.
Was wollt ihr gerade sagen?
Äh, naja. Ja, on im Discord, ne?
Ja.
Ich war ja noch so ein bisschen am schlafen.
Äh, ich bin schon wieder fast am schlafen.
Hast du mich sogar... Was? Du hast mich sogar auf Opossum TS...
Was? Du hast mich sogar auf Opossum TS...
Was? Du hast mich sogar auf Twitter zugemeldet. Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Oder hab ich das gesehen? Hab ich was drauf geantwortet?
Hallo, Mirror of Smile. Hab ich was drauf geantwortet?
Dann hab ich's gesehen. Ansonsten hab ich's vielleicht nicht gesehen.
Mich juckt das so überhaupt nicht.
Ganz ehrlich. Es ist mir so egal, Battlefield im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Kannst du meiden.
Jupp.
720p. Klar, immer 720p.
720p, ähm, hat...
...mehrere Vorteile.
Es sieht im Prinzip... Es sieht besser aus.
Es hat viel mehr Vorteile.
Es hat weniger Artefakte.
Weil Twitch bloß
6500 Mbit zulässt.
Maximale Bitrate.
Mehr geht...
6.000. Nicht 6500.
6.000.
Das heißt, das ist schon mal nicht viel.
Und da ist 1080p mit
6 Bilder in der Sekunde nicht drin.
Ähm.
Und es ist sogar einfacher zu encoden.
Also es ist eigentlich...
...alle was davon.
Tempelwächter sagt,
er hat seine Credibility verloren.
Naja, ich mein,
er hat ziemlich genau Battlefield 1 geleakt.
Und es kann ja sein,
dass es genauso ist, wie er es sagt.
Ich find, das klingt eigentlich plausibel.
Dass Dice Swain an Battlefield 1 weiterentwickelt
und daraus quasi Battlefield 1 Zweiter Weltkrieg macht.
Wie auch immer es dann heißen wird.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass sie es Battlefield 2 nennen.
Weil dann ist echt...
Dann ist die Kacke am Dampfen.
Dann blickt gar keiner mehr durch.
Ähm.
Das ist schon logisch, ja.
Und dass jetzt quasi...
Dings hier, Danger Close oder wie sie heißen.
Da die Hardline-Jungs Bad Company 3 entwickeln.
Und ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen,
dass das gar nicht so übel dort aufgehoben ist.
So.
Ready?
Mhm.
Auf geht's.
Late Night Stream.
Ja, 21 Uhr geht's los.
Heute ist nicht...
Oh, Instant Match.
Was ist da los?
Das Game ist ein bisschen leise, oder?
Das Game ist ein bisschen lauter.
Ja, jetzt ist es besser.
Ich pick...
Ach ne, Defense.
Ups.
Äh.
Da pickt eh keiner was mit Schild, ne?
Ich pick mal was mit Schild.
Und jetzt haben wir...
Oh, jetzt haben wir eine andere Moira-Heal-Kombi.
Haben wir denn...
Haben wir denn ein Mercy-Main am Start?
Ja, wir haben...
E-Iss...
E-E-E...
Eis...
Drei.
Drei Reis...
Keine Ahnung, wie der Typ heißt.
Der ist Mercy-Main.
Ne, ich hab's Game lauter gemacht.
Das müsste jetzt besser sein.
Ich muss das ja auch so abmischen, dass ich selbst alles höre in dem Game.
Äh.
The fuck?
Reinhard?
Was ist mit Reinhard los?
Der hat so ein paar Probleme gerade.
Oh, ich mach jetzt hier...
OP Firestrike.
Bye.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie der geht auf der Map, der Opening Firestrike.
Warum hast du eigentlich eine Jacke an?
Ja, Kickslot hot.
Außer ich hab hier eine Rüstung an.
Bundeswehrrüstung.
Äh, Eax, weißt du aus dem Kopf, wie man das machen konnte, dass man mit Reinhard rückwärts gucken konnte?
Das geht doch jetzt irgendwie.
Äh, Rechtsklick und Linksklick.
Ah.
Easy.
Sag mal, haben wir hier Leute irgendwo stehen?
Ah, die stehen natürlich nicht hinterm Schild.
Was der Sinn vom Schild...
Halt jetzt nicht.
Ich geh jetzt ran.
Was der Sinn vom Schild jetzt nicht unbedingt besser macht.
WTF, wie konnte ich denn da vorbeidingsen, ey?
Kickslot hot.
Scrum.
Take off the armor.
Ganz...
Das wär's noch.
Das fehlt Reinhard noch.
Ein armorless skin.
Das wär doch mal was.
Och, Moira saugt.
Moira saugt an mir.
Oh.
Sniper, Sniper, ich steck mich, ich stell mich um die Ecke.
Die Anna steht da halt ziemlich, äh...
Meine, mein Schild ist kaputt.
Ich hab gleich Ulti, ich hab gleich Ulti.
Help!
Jetzt hab ich ja nicht mal mein Chat da rausgekleckt.
Oh, da wird geschneibert.
Schneiber sind wir weg, ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
Leute, ihr müsst...
Ihr müsst noch ein bisschen zurück, ihr dürft jetzt da nicht sterben.
Oh man, die scheiß Diva hat gerade uns bei allerlei gekillt.
Ihr konnt ja einfach nicht warten mit dem Damage.
Gleich, gleich gibt's...
Gleich gibt's Shatter.
Oh nee!
Puh!
Jetzt war er wieder viel zu oft gesplittet.
Jawoll, huge Bomb!
Oh, jetzt muss ich richtig aufwachen.
Heff.
Dabei hab ich gar nicht gepennt.
Da können wir noch mal ran.
Ich geh jetzt.
Piss dich, Genji.
Piss dich, Alte.
Ich geh mal vor an die Ecke.
Nöjo.
Da moirert sich was.
Sind wir eigentlich komplett vollständig, oder ist noch einer auf dem Rückweg?
Sind alle da.
Bloß, die stehen halt gerade teilweise auf K auf der Payload.
Perfekt!
Das ist ein perfekter Spot.
Oh!
Äh.
Fuck.
Ich brauch Hilfe!
Sie können PPS bekommen.
Ähm, okay, die haben keinen Bock fortzukommen.
Ich geh mal in Voice.
Chat.
Ich hätt auch zurückkommen können.
Ich geh mal in Voice. Chat.
Aber ich verstehe ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum wir nicht ein bisschen vorpushen konnten.
Man weiß es nicht.
Ich bleib mal vor dir stehen.
Ganko.
Ganko, ja.
Ich geh mal hoch.
Wo ist die Tracer?
Ich hab gleich wieder Shatter am Start.
Prost.
Die haben jetzt...
Die ultimativen Flank-Action ist am Start.
Sag mal, wir haben doch einen McCree dabei.
Was macht denn der die ganze Zeit?
Ich weiß es nicht so genau.
So, jetzt haben wir wieder Shatter am Start.
Gleich gibt es Huge Shatter.
Huge Slam in your face.
Einfach spät gemerkt, die Anna...
Ne, ich bin doof reingecharget.
Das hat Zeit gekostet.
Was ist das?
Nack.
Man contestet zusammen und nicht alleine.
Willst du nochmal contesten gehen, oder?
Ja, ist vorbei, oder?
Ne.
Huge.
Ich zieh rein.
Das war aber auch dumm.
Ich mach mal was anderes rein, das funktioniert nicht so richtig.
Ich hüpfe da jetzt mit Winston rein.
Die haben nicht mal eine Mercy.
Ach, wir haben auch keine Mercy.
Ah, deswegen.
Deswegen ist das Match so merkwürdig.
Äh, McCree.
McCree.
Lol, Alter.
Bayonett fährt durch.
Na, wenigstens einer, der die Bubble herbefragen würde, wenn sie da schon steht.
Das wäre halt echt nice.
Oh, Heals.
Oh, erst mal richtig schwach werden.
Übelst überfordert.
Oh, das ist so.
Hanzo.
Genius ist links in dem kleinen Raum.
Fuck, Mann.
Okay.
Hanzo ist wieder da.
Help, help, help.
Heal.
Scatter.
Hast du auch Hanzo?
Komm.
Hanzo, Hanzo ihn weg.
C9.
Ich geh jetzt gleich auf Winston drauf.
Und jump da oben rein.
Gefistet.
Hanzo.
Jetzt, jetzt will er es wissen, ne?
Das kann er nicht auf sich setzen lassen, dass der Gegner Hanzo gespielt hat.
Er muss jetzt quasi Hanzo spielen.
Na gut.
Der ist, der ist, das ist, das ist ne krasse Kombination.
Der Typ ist Reinhard Hanzo Roadhog Main.
Das ist, beziehungsweise eigentlich ist er Reinhard Hanzo Main.
Das ist ne Kombination, die sieht man tatsächlich ziemlich selten.
Was hat denn dieser Lust?
Der Lust kann ruhig wieder D.Va spielen.
Wäre Saria nicht die bessere Alternative gewesen?
Saria ist halt null mobil.
Bam.
Das Stuhl ist schuld.
Nicht das Feuer.
Das ist natürlich auch ne gute Erklärung.
Wenn er mit den Pfeilen sich trifft, dann mit dem Hammer.
Das ist, könnte die Kombination erklären.
Wahrscheinlich spielt er immer wieder Hanzo, sagt übelst, trifft nix und denkt, dass ich komm, nachkampftreffe ich.
Ja, das kann sein.
Guck mal, ob hier irgendein Junkrat trapped ist.
Nope.
Schieben wir schön an die Ecke, schieben wir und dann geht's.
Druff.
Ich geb dir mal Damage Boost.
Ich hüpf mal raus.
Auf die Tracer, die hier irgendwo rumspringt.
Push mal weiter, ich geh gleich wieder hoch.
Oh, oben ist nix.
Da fuck.
Oh, da ist was.
Sei ja.
Mach platt.
Die stehen alle dahinter.
Push mal weiter.
Ich laser die, sobald sie hier rauskommen.
Easy.
Was denn das?
Da passiert ja gar nix.
Ich geh gleich weiter vor.
Ist der Reaper, war der Reaper auf dem Dach?
Ich hab's zu kurz gesehen.
Ja, war er.
Mercy!
Genji muss es natürlich übertreiben.
Ich übertreib's auch grad voll.
My Maker Discom.
Äh.
Oh.
Warum ist die Ulti nicht raus?
Gib ihm.
Du musst wieder rauskommen.
Oh ne.
Gib ihm weiter.
Gib ihm noch mehr.
Gib ihm was, die oben.
Ich bin oben, nicht die anderen.
Gib ihm.
Gib eben.
Süßes Objekt.
Alter, was ist das denn hier für ein Match gerade?
Los.
Da fuck.
2000 HP winst ein FTW.
Ja.
Hast du gesehen, wie schnell ich in Ulti tot war?
Ich halt mal unseren Genji.
Oh.
Das war...
Alter Schwede.
Oh.
Das hat reingehauen.
Kommt man da hoch?
Ne.
Hinter dir, äh.
Da.
Oh.
Die Reaper Flank.
No.
Alter, wieso killt ihn denn keiner?
What the fuck?
Echt jetzt?
Scatter.
Da ist...
Genji zieht mit seiner Beyblade.
Wir haben schon eine tiefe Armstange.
Was ist denn das für ein Game?
Ich habe gefühlt nichts gemacht.
Wozu noch?
Da steht ein McCree.
Ist schon vorgegangen.
Oh, der Reaps, oh.
Er transt.
Ich muss weg.
Das war knapp.
Noch einmal regruppen, pushen, easy win.
Wir können jetzt einfach mal regroupen, Leute.
Regroupen, come on.
So eine schöne Mei holt auf die Payload.
Come on, screw.
Zarya.
Oh, fuck.
Jetzt aber.
Kannst du nach hinten schwingen?
Easy.
Ja, dann kann man.
Der Hanzo.
Der Hanzo hat gecarried, ja.
Sehr spannend.
Sehr spannender Play.
Ultra spannendes Play of the Game.
Er hat zwei Headshots gemacht.
Krass, sehr nice.
Der Wahnsinn.
Ey, weißt du, wofür Mercy gut ist?
Wenn du so fett gefressen bist, dass du keinen Bock mehr hast zu spielen.
Ja, linksklick.
Ab und zu mal Q.
First win of the day.
Ich bin mal kurz zwei Minuten weg.
Ja, mach das.
Ich poste den Krempel jetzt mal auf Twitter.
Auf YouTube posten, den ganzen Krempel.
Ich habe das letzte Mal gefragt.
Und ihr habt gesagt, jawohl.
Please.
Immer auf YouTube ankündigen.
Dann mache ich das jetzt auch mal.
Also Max, was ist mit einem Update zu den einzelnen Helden?
Äh, was meinst du genau?
Du meinst ein Video zu jedem Held?
Meinst du das?
Moin, Aster015.
Ach ja, die ganzen Follows, die gestern reingekommen sind.
Äh, vorgestern.
Oder wann habe ich zuletzt gestreamt?
Gestern?
Vorgestern?
Ich bin verwirrt.
Ich weiß das gar nicht mehr.
Aber, sieht man auch nicht mehr richtig.
Lull.
Du hattest am Anfang von Overwatch mal jeden Helden kurz angeschnitten.
Stimmt, ja, ja, habe ich.
Aber ich habe zwei Videos gemacht.
Zwei Videos, wo ich zu jedem Held mal drei, vier Minuten was gesagt habe.
Wäre mal angebracht bei den ganzen Neuen.
Ah.
Ich glaube, da muss ich erst ein bisschen länger spielen wieder.
Und ich habe das Gefühl irgendwie, dass Overwatch kaum einer sehen will bei mir auf dem Channel.
Also zumindest.
Also man als Hintergrund-Gameplay, okay, sagt im Endeffekt.
Keiner was.
Da kannst du auch fast alles nehmen.
Aber vielleicht mal Schach außen vor gelassen oder sowas.
Ähm.
An den meisten Leuten ging es immer übelst auf den Sack, wenn ich irgendwas über Overwatch gebracht habe.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Ich werde ein 100 plus Soldier-Gameplay sehen.
Nuller KD.
Mit Nuke oder ohne?
Oder Moab?
Ich mache das erste Overwatch-Moab-Video.
Das Team Moab.
Machst du mal ein Video wieder auf deinem Overwatch-Channel?
Ich bin gerade komplett ausgelastet mit Videos auf meinem Main-Channel machen und ab und zu mal streamen.
Da kriege ich nichts hin.
Ich werde mit ein paar, ich hoffe zumindest, dass ich demnächst mit ein paar Overwatch-Channels was mache.
Hauptsächlich wahrscheinlich bei denen, weil da die Leute sind, die Overwatch-Content interessiert.
Ähm.
Mal gucken was.
Auf jeden Fall.
Was ist denn das für ein Video, das zu Overwatch liegt?
Hexer-Nuke.
Oh, könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern?
Könnt ihr euch noch an dieses komische Rum-Gehälter erinnern, wer von wem die Penta-Nuke geklaut hat?
Oder wie war das nochmal?
Ich kriege das gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen.
Es hat doch von irgendjemand, irgendjemand hat Penta-Nuke-Gameplay nicht, oder war das Gameplay geklaut und die hat zuerst Penta-Nuke hochgelassen?
Das war ein, damals, das war so ein Affenseros, ey.
Vor allem, was für ein Scheiß man sich damals aufgeregt hat, ne?
Ich weiß noch, der Tio.
Der Tio hat irgendwann mal den Fabian, also den, den, den Friseur gebannt.
Und das war total, er hat total hängen geblieben eigentlich.
Und über die Sachen, wo du dich damals aufgeregt hast, da gerät heute kein Hahn mehr danach.
Ne, ne, das war nicht Rambo-Yolo-Hater, das war nicht Rambo.
Den gab's auch damals, ja.
Ja, das war was.
Da hat man sich, damals hat man sich echt über Blödsinn aufgeregt, wo du dir heute denkst, so, ja, pff, who cares.
Was?
Ich mein, heute los?
Ich weiß es ja auch gar nicht, aber es ist nicht irgendwie großartig, drüber aufzuregen.
Wisst ihr, was ich, jetzt mal zur Abwechslung, ja?
Wisst ihr, was ich als guten, naja, Trend, es ist kein Trend, ja?
Was ich aber als ganz gute Entwicklung auf YouTube empfinde, zumindest im englischsprachigen Raum.
Im deutschen Raum, im deutschen Raum auch ein bisschen, aber ich mein, YouTube Deutschland ist halt voll mit, ja, low, so, so quasi Einzel-Gehirn-Content, ja?
Ähm.
Ähm, im englischsprachigen Raum gibt's sau viele Science-Channels, also jetzt nicht so, nicht so dieses, dieses total übertriebene, so nach dem Motto, wir zeigen euch jetzt den gleichen Scheiß, den wir euch immer zeigen, machen aber da einen riesen Tam-Tam drumherum, nee, sondern so wirklich, so, so Space-Time gibt's da beispielsweise als Channel und sowas, find ich richtig cool.
Die sich dann beschäftigen so mit, was weiß ich, das Universum, die Galaxie, das Sonnensystem, bla, so, so Science-Channel, gibt's total viel im englischsprachigen Raum und die gucken auch viel und werden auch viel empfohlen und sowas und das ist wirklich richtig guter Content bei vielen.
In Deutschland gibt's da auch so ein bisschen was, aber das, find ich, ist eine ganz gute Entwicklung.
Ich mein, noch mehr Scheiße braucht man ja auch nicht.
Ich mein, irgendwann ist ja auch mal die Scheiße, die jemand konsumieren kann, die man braucht, gesättigt, ja?
Die verteilt sich höchstens noch weiter.
Aber okay.
So was wie Klarname, sowas wie Kurzgesagten, sowas, das kenn ich gar nicht.
Little Samsung, ja, N24-Dokus sind totaler Müll.
Auf N24 läuft gefühlt jeden zweiten Tag die größten Flugzeugträger der Welt oder sowas, zumindest als ich früher noch geguckt hab.
Und was ist mit IT-Mythen?
So, wieder da, sorry.
Ja, soll ich queuen?
Ja.
Easy.
Und was ist mit IT-Mythen?
Ja, mach ich, mach ich auch wieder.
Ich hab schon ein paar Ideen, aber ich brauch da halt so vier, fünf Sachen, wo ich mich...
Was sind...
Los, warum geht denn das so schnell?
Ja, siehst du doch, im anderen Team ist ein Diamond drin.
Jetzt müssen sie wohl testen, ob man nicht, ne, 1500 Abstand machen kann.
Zwischen den Spielern.
Wahrscheinlich.
Kann wer gute Grind-Games empfehlen?
Ja.
Aber erstmal noch eine Frage.
Suchst du eher einen MMO?
Oder sowas wie Diablo 2?
Also suchst du jetzt eher was, so, ja, quasi halt so mit Open World und vielen Leuten unterwegs und sonst was?
Oder suchst du so Diablo-mäßig?
Hack and Slay.
Hast du Bock?
Wobei, nee, ich pack mal Roadhog ein.
Äh...
Probieren wir's mal.
Ansonsten gehst du halt rein, wenn du Bock hast.
Wir haben wieder keine Mercy.
Wenn die Gegner Mercy haben, ist das quasi schon wieder Instant-Lose.
Ja, ich würd ja Mercy picken, ne.
Ne, wir haben ja so ne...
Na, wir haben ja den Moira Main.
Wie viele Stunden hat er denn?
Sieben Stunden und danach Mercy.
Krass.
Viele Leute...
Naja, bei MMO hätt ich die auch BDO empfohlen.
Ja.
Das ist das Client-Game schlechthin.
Aber, wenn du irgendwas suchst Richtung Diablo 2, spiel Path of Exile.
Das ist das beste Action-RPG, das beste Diablo-Hack and Slay-like-Game, was es gibt zurzeit.
Also, was heißt zurzeit, das ist es schon seit 1-2 Jahren.
2-3 Jahren sogar, das gibt's ja schon ein bisschen.
Path of Exile ist das beste in der Richtung.
Mit Abstand.
Und...
Weee!
Oh nein, Junkrat-Spam-Kacke.
Ich hüpfe jetzt hier rein.
Weee!
Oh!
Out of Mac.
Ich bin hinten drinne.
Ich brauch Help.
Musst du wieder rauskommen.
Wo war's doch mit dir gewesen.
Das war's mit mir auch.
So auf dem Rückweg.
Guckt Leute, und deswegen braucht man eine Mercy.
Oh, ich hätte mir's aufhören müssen.
Das ist ein bisschen...
Oh, ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Oh, ich hätte mir's auf nehmen sollen.
Indem ich so über's Dach hüpfe.
Das war nicht das beste Beispiel, aber es hätte durchaus sein können, dass die Leute...
Dass die Gegner das nur halten, weil sie eine Mercy haben.
Ich werde gleich mal Hauch auf das Dach hüpfen.
Urch, du Scheiße!
Hast du's ja anders überlegt.
Nein.
Der Junkrat hat sich das anders überlegt.
F**k, ich kann da ja nicht hoch.
Lass mich mal von unten.
Ich hole ihn in den Pack.
Schild.
Schieben, schieben, schieben.
Ich springe jetzt hoch.
Der Soldier hüpft runter.
Der ist lebenswürde.
Nein, nein, nein.
Da falle ich nicht rein auf den Scheiß.
Zum Glück hat man den Rammenschuss der Aktion.
Ich habe gerade das Laufen verkackt.
Bin nicht mehr hinter die Leitung gekommen.
Was?
Fuck.
Lull.
Und tschüss.
Und noch einer weg.
Ich kicke die zu euch.
Oh, oh, ich muss weg.
Easy, easy clap.
Okay, pushen.
Das war doch ein nices Winston-Play.
Das war ja mal die easiest Wunde Icon-Walt, die ich je hatte.
Ja, das war, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, die Gegner hatten keinen Bock.
Ich gebe zu, es war ein schlechtes Beispiel für, warum die Gegner gewinnen.
Wenn sie Mercy haben und wir nicht.
Aber normalerweise, ja Leute, normalerweise ist das so.
Vor allem mit Defense.
Das ist so geil, wenn du einfach jemanden wiederbeleben kannst, der nicht vom Spawn vorlaufen muss.
Ja gut, das zweite Checkpoint war ja übel für den Arsch für die Gegner.
Da sind die alle runtergeschmissen worden.
Was willst du denn da so pressen?
Ja, Little Samsung Skype verwendet auch keiner mehr.
Heute ist Discord.
Ist angesagt.
Was ist das?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die...
Die etwas jüngeren, ob da noch Snapchat und sowas angesagt ist.
Ein Programm, wo sich mir das Sinn noch nie erschlossen hat, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Hast du Preseason OVL geguckt?
Ja, alles.
Alle Matches.
Skype TeamSpeak.
Das Discord-Beste.
Ich meine, es ist eine kack Elektron-JavaScript-Browser im Fenster-Anwendung, die massig RAM frisst, Discord.
Aber eines der wenigen Anwendungsfälle, wo ich das...
Okay finde.
Weil man will den ganzen Scheiß auch immer neu programmieren.
Jawoll, Hit.
Oh, oh, oh, der Fist, der Fist fistet.
Hanzo, Hanzo.
Scatter.
Schild kaputt.
Oh, ich bin gesleept.
No.
Links ist der Roadhog drin.
Fuck.
Siehste, Leute.
Und jetzt wäre eine Mercy Gold wert.
Unsere Leute recken die natürlich auch so.
Weil anscheinend die Gegner keine Lust haben, ordentlich zu spielen.
Aber jetzt wäre eine Mercy Gold wert gewesen.
Ja.
Gejreckt.
Hanzo steht an der Ecke.
Ich bin klar wieder vorne.
Ich kann da wenig dagegen machen gerade.
Links, links, McBee drin.
Achtung, Achtung, Mitte.
Mitte, Hanzo.
Mein Schild ist kaputt.
Äh, okay.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, was die Gegner machen, um ehrlich zu sein.
Solche Sachen.
Ja, solche Sachen.
Ja, warum machen die das, ist die Frage.
Oh, nein.
Nice hit.
Gleich Ulti am Start, 7%.
Oh.
Huge.
Äh, nicht so huge.
Ah ja.
Scheiße, dass der geultet hat.
Schild kaputt.
Ah, ich bin dauernd.
Was haben die denn?
Schon mal der Aff raus.
Perfekt.
Ah, hat korrekt.
Oh, nee.
Das war waste.
Das war hardcore waste.
Nicht, dass wir den gleichen Kack jetzt machen, wie die Gegner.
Next, next, excuse me.
Fuck.
Schöpf mal runter.
Ich geh runter, run.
Ist irgendwie total entspannt gerade.
Ja, ich weiß einfach, was wir so genau machen.
Komm mal ein Stückchen zurück, Leute.
Ich bin wieder oben.
Die kommen nicht so wirklich vor, oder?
Okay, ich geh runter.
Der Rock, der Rock ist unten noch.
Der Rock ist noch hinter uns.
Nee, ist weg.
Trick 17. Moin, Bento.
Wieso haben die eigentlich so viel Zeit auf der Uhr?
Das ist noch eigentlich ganz ungehalten.
Wir haben es nicht so lang gehalten.
Das ist der erste Punkt.
Das kommt mir gerade einfach so langsam vor.
Sag mal, wenn die engagen.
Ich seh's nicht richtig.
Das sind gerade Split.
Payload wird gepusht von Roadie.
Ich geh drauf.
Oh, sleep.
Nein! Outplayed.
Du bist outplayed.
Zu weit gespielt.
Fuck, fail.
Ich spiel zwar eigentlich auch lieber, ja, ab und zu.
Das war fail.
RIP.
All die Zeit ist gut.
Ich bleib hinten stehen.
Ich hab keinen Bock wieder zu.
Das ist dergang jetzt.
Wir können da nochmal contesten.
Ich geh da klar drauf.
Warte noch, bis die Leute da sind vom Spawn.
Ja, natürlich.
Moira, ey.
Okay, jetzt.
Ich hab die Runde nicht wirklich was gemacht.
Kann man eigentlich, wenn man das ordentlich zielt.
Wie ist da der richtige Winkel?
Funktioniert ja.
Muss noch einer auf der Payload bleiben, damit er nicht gepusht wird.
Das war ja ein mega entspanntes Match.
I don't know.
Was ist da los?
Der ist dumm fest.
Victory Pause.
Was hältst du von Kryptowährung?
Also ich finde, es ist eine gute Sache.
Was ist mit dem Soldier passiert?
What the fuck?
Der wurde deleted.
Der Reinhard wurde deleted.
Wahnsinn, ey.
Ich zieh raus.
Ja, Kryptowährung.
An sich finde ich, ist Kryptowährung eine gute Sache.
Ich meine, das ist ja jetzt wieder 50.
Tausend verschiedene Kryptowährungen braucht.
Jetzt versucht jeder, ein bisschen so sein Stück vom Kuchen abzukriegen.
Weil er jetzt spekulieren soll, den Kryptowährungen.
Keine Ahnung.
Da bin ich da falsch für.
So, ich suche, ne?
Mhm.
Das war easy wins heute.
Ino Sakai sagt, hatte heute zwei Runden lang einen Typ im Team, der in Defense instant Symmetra gepickt hat, weil Symmetra laut ihm doch besser sei als Mercy.
Ja.
Es gibt Leute, die spielen einfach Symmetra, um Symmetra zu spielen.
Oder Attack-Turb.
Äh, Attack-Turb.
Boah.
Äh, ihr wisst, was ich meine, oder?
Also sprich, Attack-Turb.
Kack-Turb meine ich.
Attack-Turb gibt's auch.
Die machen das einfach.
Weil sie das geil finden.
Und ja, laut Blizzard.
Auch wenn sich ein bisschen widerspricht, ne?
Wenn wir jetzt hier mal auf Report gehen.
Kann man hier reporten vor Port Teamwork?
So.
Port Teamwork ist zum Beispiel, ähm,
Not trying to complete Map Objective.
Das ist Port Teamwork.
Und das Beste ist, Port Teamwork ist
NOT
den falschen Hero picken.
Bin ich der einzige,
der irgendwie findet, das widerspricht sich?
Ich weiß nicht.
Sollen sie sich mal überlegen, was sie wollen bei Blizzard.
Sonst ist das Spiel in einem Jahr tot.
So hart das klingt jetzt.
Es hat
so viele Spieler schon verloren.
Sogar die Koreaner spielen.
Die spielen das nicht mehr.
Und die waren Feuer und Flamme für das Game.
Ah, guck mal, Left-Click.
Da haben wir ihn doch.
Wie auch immer es im Chat geschrieben hat.
Ist das dein Symmetra Main, ja?
Ist der das?
Guck jetzt mal in den Chat, ob er das ist.
Ist er das, Left-Click?
Ähm.
Warte mal, ich bin ein wenig verwirrt.
Der Symmetra
One-Trick, der müsste ja eigentlich nach dem ersten
Nein, der müsste nix.
Der hat 32 Stunden Symmetra, sonst nichts.
Ähm.
Das heißt, er spielt das ganze
Match Symmetra. Das heißt, wir können ohne
Probleme noch einen zweiten Support picken,
oder? Sehe ich das richtig?
Sowas wie Zenyatta zum Beispiel.
Aber eigentlich muss man Mercy spielen, wenn wir den Scheiß
noch irgendwie gewinnen wollen.
Denken wir irgendwie.
Das Problem ist,
der Typ,
den müssen wir einfach als DPS zählen.
Symmetra. Den müssen wir einfach als
DPS zählen.
Der wird dann ordentlich
gen Anuboost, dann passt er schon.
Das ist auch
so ne Sache. Warum
kann man solche Typen nicht reporten? Warum ist
das laut Blizzard okay?
Die haben ja Widowmaker, wir brauchen ja oben gar
nicht stehen.
Der Typ hat Diamond,
okay.
Ich hör,
ich hör die Widow.
Wir müssen auf die Widow aufpassen. Ich bleib hier in der Ecke stehen.
Pass auf, pass auf.
Der Junkrat ist oben allein.
Wo ist denn die Widow? Hast du ne Ahnung?
Nee.
Ich versuch dir mal zu. Nein, ich kann den nicht wiederbeleben.
Wenn ich den wiederbelebe, bin ich tot.
That Movement. Links ist die Mercy.
Soldier.
Unten. Mei.
So, Ulti am Start.
Wie genau halten wir das jetzt?
Mit Symmetra-Turrets.
Und wo ist
die Widowmaker?
Ah, vorne.
Mitte irgendwo müsste es sein.
Ich kann da grad nicht
peeken.
Ich hab Schiss, da zu
peeken. Und ich hab auch
Schiss, rumzufliegen.
Da ist was drinne hier am Payload.
Easy Damage Mercy.
Rekt!
Hm, komisch.
Oh, die Widow ist grad auf den Spawn gehüpft.
Mercy ist
not hot. Nein, Mercy ist wirklich beim besten Willen nicht
hot. Vor allem in den nächsten
Spielern ist Mercy definitiv nicht hot.
Ich bleib mal mit Heal auf dir drauf.
Ich kann halt nicht
peeken gegen die Widow. Mach den rein,
mach den rein halt. Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Der hat dich so angeguckt, als hat er
Instant Shatter jetzt schon, als hat er schon gedrückt quasi.
DPS Mercy, lol.
Hinter uns ist die Widow.
Oh, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Ich spamme ein bisschen AD.
Damage Boost, Damage Boost, Damage Boost.
Ich AD spamme mir
den...
Wo ist die Anna?
NEIN!
Geslammed!
Ja, das Symmetra
da hat es jetzt mal richtig...
Das hat schon Erfolg gebracht, muss man sagen, ja.
Okay, go, go, go.
Okay, go, go, go, go.
Noch nicht, noch nicht, noch nicht.
Hey, fünf Schuss.
Fünf Schuss und ich krieg...
Pass auf, die Widow auf.
Ich hab Schiss, die Widow geht voll auf mich drauf.
Was ein Hold.
Oh, fuck, Alter.
Wo ist, wo ist die Widow? Wo ist die Widow?
Im Spawn.
Ich hör einen Reinhardt hier anrücken.
Fuck, die haben den Punkt gekriegt.
Oh, nein.
Das hab ich überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt.
Wie haben die denn den Punkt gekriegt?
Puh.
Oh, oh.
Die haben den Punkt gekriegt.
Verdammt, ich dachte schon, wir haben jetzt gewonnen.
Nach dem Fight.
Fuck.
Zwei HP überlebt, ey.
Ich bin gleich wieder bei dir.
Ich muss vom Spawn vorlaufen.
Widow oben links, ich kann nicht raus.
Kann nicht in die Mitte.
Also, die ist da in der Kirche.
In der Kirche ist die Widow oben drin gewesen.
Ich komm zu dir hoch.
Hätte ich noch Roadhog Hook 1.0, dann...
Komm.
Andere Seite, ich muss mich verstecken.
Jetzt bin ich down.
Verstecken sich gerade alle.
Jetzt können wir, glaube ich.
Ja.
Auf.
Go, go.
Ah, das war vielleicht eine Ulti, die war unnötig.
Die Widow ist wieder oben.
Kannst du mich hoch?
Ach, Quatsch. Ich komm nicht hoch.
Winston, Winston, Winston.
Achso, du bist ja gar nicht mehr Winston.
Oh, YOLO Winston, YOLO Winston.
Ich bin down.
Das siehst du denen immer schon richtig an, ne?
Die haben so...
Als würden die Augen leuchten.
Aber irgendwie kriegt das sonst keiner mit.
Wir schlagen uns bis jetzt wirklich...
...beachtlich...
Ich geh zurück.
...beachtlich gut.
Leute, Leute, Leute.
Nicht aufextenden, nicht. Nein!
Okay, das halten wir jetzt.
Easy hold, easy hold.
Ich hab ein bisschen Schiss vor der Widow.
Ach, die haben keine Widow mehr.
Die Fahrer.
War das die Widow?
Oh, Scheiße.
Ich sag's noch, ne?
Wir haben keine Widow mehr, nur Fahrer.
Bam, in your face.
Ist das jetzt hier Early Night Stream?
Ja, quasi.
Gott, ey.
Wie soll denn das fun...
Ja, ich konteste gerade.
Soll denn die Scheiße hier funktionieren?
Mein Gott!
Ich komm grad noch so nicht rein.
Wenn da noch einer... Oh Mann, Scheiße.
Ah, Mann.
Ich hätte fast Ulti gehabt.
Ich konnte nicht ran.
Ich hätte auch fast Ulti gehabt.
So, Leute, ernsthaft. Warum kann man so einen Vollspast nicht reporten?
Ist das etwa nicht pure Teamwork?
Pure Teamwork?
Oder wie auch immer Scheißwort ausspricht?
Select your hero.
Ähm...
Lass das mal probieren.
Haut einfach Bastion of Attack raus,
dann ist das easy Clap.
Machen wir ja gerade. Sind wir auch gerade dabei.
Also, wenn das nicht
am Team vorbei gearbeitet ist,
weiß ich auch nicht.
Vor allem mit einem Held, der schon so heiß,
der nur dafür gemacht ist, für so einen Scheiß.
So was ist okay, wenn man das in Quickplay
und sonst was macht.
Ich mein, soll das ein Competitive-Modus sein
oder ist das eine Witzfigur?
Ich mein, ich spiel auch
die ganzen Helden, auf die ich keinen Bock hab.
Warum?
Ich will, dass wir gewinnen und weil ich weiß, dass wir Competitive spielen.
Weil wir Rank spielen.
Dann wären
die ganze Heldenvielfalt unnütz, wenn
immer nur feste Helden gespielt werden.
Ja, das Problem daran ist, wenn es nicht Viable ist,
wenn es halt eben nicht
die beste Sache ist, die du picken kannst,
dann ist es einmal ein Fail auf Seiten von
Blizzard, dass es immer so eingeschränktes
Meta gibt, aber auf der anderen Seite ist es in fast jedem
Game so, dass es ein... Naja, in
Meta in irgendeiner Art und Weise gibt.
Aber ich mein, das Ding heißt ja nicht umsonst
Competitive.
Das kann man überall machen.
Aber wenn dieser Modus wirklich was taugen soll
und ernst genommen werden soll, dann ist das
einfach quasi hart am
Griefing dran.
Ich war in einer Junkrat-Trap.
Siehst du was?
Mhm.
Wir haben jetzt halt nicht mehr richtig Heal, ne?
Wir haben bloß die Ana.
Chilled ist gleich kaputt.
500, 400, 300.
Ich bau ab.
Ich schieb mal weiter.
Junkrat ist unten dran.
Da gehen wir jetzt drauf.
Der wird jetzt gereckt.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, das ist noch ein Reinhardt.
Ich werd jetzt...
Ich war auf der Payload.
Warum kann der mich da runterzahmen?
Weiß nicht, ob die nochmal wollen.
Die wollen nochmal.
Echt.
Lasst euch mal nicht hitten,
Jungs.
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund sich jetzt hier...
Nein, ich wollt grad ne Schilderung machen.
Fuck.
Das kann die Ana nicht heilen.
Aber ich hab gleich Shatter.
Na, ey, ey. Easy. Was macht ihr da?
Weiter geht's.
Jetzt wird geschattert, Clay.
Shatterclap.
Hör ich nen Reaper über uns?
Mhm, ich bau mich anders auf.
Ich schatter gleich.
Ich schatter den, wenn er runterkommt.
Die Mercy ist oben.
Haha.
Wreck der Renote.
Der will nochmal.
Er hat noch nicht. Wer will nochmal?
Sieht so aus.
Jetzt kommt die schwere Ecke, jetzt kommt die schwere Ecke her.
Oh.
Benötigt es ab.
Danke, dass du mich rausschmeißt.
Weiße.
Die denken halt alle.
Sie müssen mitdenken für dich.
Danke.
Oh.
Oben der Reaper, der Reaper.
Der guckt schon so.
Der springt auf dich drauf.
Ja, da kommt er, da kommt er, da kommt er, da kommt er.
Oh, die Seier hat mich hochgezogen.
Eben noch.
What?
Okay, wir haben einen Pick.
Wir sind mehr, Leute.
Uns beeilen.
Nee, wir haben keinen Heiler.
Fuck. Wo ist er?
Okay, nice.
Nein, wenn wir da reingehen, ist es wrecked.
Ich geh unten lang, ich geh unten lang.
Liegen alle, alle.
Oh nein, du lockst sie weg.
Mach ich nicht.
Nix passiert.
Ich hab nicht gechargt.
Uuuuh.
Nee, dein Mini hat die alle
in Out of Sight geknuddelt.
Das war dann doof.
Und ich hab auch nochmal einen Charge auf den Reinhardt verkackt.
Beste Sache.
Die Ecke ist halt echt das Problem.
Hier warst du über mir.
Okay, ich warte mal, ich komm mit, ich komm mit, ich komm mit.
Okay, go, go.
Nein!
Alter, ich renn immer in diese verkackte Falle.
Schild ist weg da.
Du shaderst mich nicht, Alter.
Nice.
Was ist deine Meinung zu Escape from Tarkov?
Schon mal angesehen, finde es
sieht relativ interessant aus.
Ist das, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was das ist.
Ist das dieses Battle Royale?
Hahaha.
Nice.
Lol.
Ist es dieses Battle Royale im kalten Krieg
oder so, oder im zweiten Weltkrieg, oder was war das?
Nee, äh, Felix,
das haben die auch schon klargestellt,
das One Tricking ist in Ordnung
und vor allem auch, dass das Picken
von dem im Held, den keiner braucht,
ich weiß halt nicht, warum das dann immer noch Competitive heißt,
aber die werden ihr eigenes Spiel schon zugrunde richten,
wenn es um diese Sache geht.
Guckt mal in Quickplay rein,
Samstagabend braucht ihr zwei Minuten,
um ein Match zu finden
und die Hälfte besteht schon aus Smurfs.
Das hat auch einen Grund, warum Blizzard
keine Spielerzahlen rausgibt.
Wenn die Spielerzahlen
übelst geil wären, so nach dem Motto
wir haben jetzt 20 Millionen verkaufte Spiele,
10 Millionen Spieler, wisst ihr also irgendwas richtig,
was man richtig vorzahlen kann?
Glaubt ihr, die Marketingabteilung von Blizzard
wird uns zuscheißen mit Spielerzahlen?
So gut können die nicht sein.
Kommt jetzt gleich die Widow
und die Symmetra.
Die Tracer ist bestimmt durch.
Die kommt bestimmt gleich rechts, die Tracer.
Ich hör sie schon, ich hör sie schon.
Ich geh auch kurz an der Wand.
Ich mein, wir sind 6 gegen 5, ne?
Wir contesten jetzt.
Ich geh ran.
Die Mercy ist als einzige am Payload.
WTF?
Was ist hier los? Warum sterben die alle?
Tracer kommt.
Oh, scheiße.
QXX.
Ist das exklusiv fake?
Das war aber ein typischer Fall von
zu leicht genommen,
weil 6 gegen 5.
Ich hab rechts was gehört.
Ja, Tracer kommt von hinten.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, jetzt geht's ran hier.
Attacke!
Widow ist in der Mitte.
Ich bleib einfach mit dem Schild vor ihr stehen.
Die Tracer ist schon hinter mir.
Okay.
Und da geht der Nächste.
Das ist voll competitive, man.
Diese 3800
ist eher spiegelbein.
Können voll wieder.
Ja, auch der Symmetra-Warn-Trick,
der trägt richtig so einfach zur
Wettkampf-Atmosphäre bei.
Findest du nicht auch?
Ja, das geht voll ab.
Das ist das neue Meta.
Das ist das neue Overwatch-League.
Nächstes Jahr. Symmetra.
Attack Symmetra. Jedem Team.
Weil es so competitive ist.
Irgendwann...
Taimou wird bekannt für seine Symmetra.
Ich seh's schon kommen.
Dann gibt's den Internet-Hulk
Symmetra-Reward irgendwann.
Wobei der echt krasse
Symmetra-Plays hatte
in den ersten paar Turnieren.
Das ist auch ein geiler Bug, ne?
Wenn der Leave-Button nicht funktioniert.
Das geht?
Hatte ich noch nie.
Hattest du das schon mal?
Ich auch noch nie.
Ich glaub, der trollt.
Ja, weil ich auch nicht 10 Jahre drinnebleibe,
wenn ich's schon sehe, dass der Leave-Button dabei ist.
Der trollt.
Der wird so weg-tryhardet
mit Passion plus Reinhardt-Schild.
6 vs 1. Easy.
Da ist er.
Der kommt gleich von hinten.
Nein. Scatter!
Scatter. Scatter.
Scatter.
Ja, das war knapp.
Das war knapp, ja.
Jetzt kommt's. Bam.
Huge. Huge Plays.
Da rutscht
er durch die Türbe.
Sick Plays, man.
Sick. Hast du aufgenommen. Nehm auf.
Richtig sicke Plays.
Falls du's nicht hast, dann nehm mal rückwirkend auf.
Das kann man.
Ich hab gerade halb AFK gespielt.
Ja, aber, aber.
Aber, was ich nämlich mal probieren wollte,
ich wollte mal gucken,
wenn ich aufnehme, also hier Shadowplay
die gleiche Map und du,
ich wollte mich einfach mal dran probieren,
so ein Dual-View
Dings zusammenzuschneiden.
Weißt du, wie ich mein? Also, dass du quasi
das gleiche Match aus zwei unterschiedlichen
Sichten siehst, halt immer ordentlich
abwechselnd geschnitten.
So dass du quasi zwei Perspektiven hast in einem Match.
Wollt ich mal ausprobieren, wie ich das hinkrieg.
So, heute. Huge Plays.
Heute sind wir ja schon bei 3-0.
Das ist aber auf jeden Fall gar nichts.
Egal.
Kannst du nicht mehr rückwirkend aufnehmen.
Wobei, nee, Quatsch. Wir müssen das nicht bringen.
Ich hab das ja alles ausgeschaltet.
Halb AFK, aber du hast schon recht.
Taimo best Symmetra.
Jawoll. Ich sag euch, Overwatch League.
Taimo wird bekannt für seine Symmetra.
Ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Ja.
Geh mal da.
Exklusiv für seinen Torbjörn.
Ich sehe es richtig
vor mir, ja.
MVP Awards bei der ersten
Overwatch League. Taimo als Symmetra.
Ja. Weil so competitive
ist das halt.
So, hab ich irgendwas überlesen? Ich schau mal kurz rein.
Damals
Free Weekend, wo jeder mal spielen konnte, erstes
Game richtig hart verloren im Killfeed,
waren nur noch die Gegner.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Problem. Das ist wirklich
könnte ich mir vorstellen
für Leute, die quasi bei
einem kostenlosen Wochenende mal mitspielen,
das ist hardcore frustrierend.
Wenn du ganz neu in dem Game bist
und einfach
auf den Sack kriegst. Das Game ist zwar so gedacht, dass du
die ersten paar Matches kriegst du ja nur
Leute, die quasi auch auf
diesem Level sind. Aber es gibt mittlerweile
so viele Smurfs und ich will nicht wissen, wie
viele gute Spieler zum Free Weekend
einen neuen Account gemacht haben. Einfach halt für Free Weekend
Noobs bashen.
Wer lässt sich schon die Chance zum Noobs bashen
entgehen? Wahrscheinlich nicht viele.
Hallo, I reap in.
Wobblos hype.
Der Wobblos, ja.
Keks not hot.
Du plus du is four.
Inosaki, Seagull of May, ja.
Das Spiel übertrieben gut, May.
Es gibt eigentlich kaum was, was
Seagull nicht gut spielt, von den hellen Ligas spielt.
Tracer ist ein bisschen
eingerostet, spielt er aber auch nicht.
Er hat mal ganz am Anfang
als es noch Beta war
und sein Team das gebraucht hat, wo
Double Tracer angesagt war,
hat er Tracer gespielt
und hat es damals schon gehasst.
Aber May spielt er echt gut.
Ich würde fast sagen,
einer der besten May-Spiele, die es gibt.
Und das jetzt nicht irgendwie
so, ich meine das ernst.
Da freue ich mich
auch drauf. Ich freue mich vor allem in der Overwatch League
wirklich jetzt mal Seagull spielen zu
sehen und auch exklusive
da spielen zu sehen.
Nach diesem ganzen Hickhack da drum herum.
Gucken ob er jetzt am Ende für ein paar Matches
gesperrt ist oder nicht.
LittleSamsung sagt, May finde ich
extrem schwer gut zu spielen.
Was bei May schwer ist, halt Rechtsklick zu treffen.
Das war in der Beta übrigens,
wer es nicht gespielt hat.
Was die wenigsten haben, ja.
Also in der Beta war May Rechtsklick
viel schwerer zu treffen, der war langsamer.
Jetzt ist es ja, wenn man hier reinguckt,
kann man, darf ich eigentlich in die Training oder?
Nein, darf ich natürlich nicht in der Gruppe.
Also, jetzt ist es so, wenn du
Rechtsklick drückst, der lädt sich relativ schnell auf
bei May. Das macht dann
Also das geht.
In der Beta hat es gemacht
Also das war gefühlt dreimal
langsamer in der Beta. Und sogar da
hat Seagull die Rechtsklick-Headshots getroffen,
wie sonst was.
GPOP fragt, hey Max
Oh übrigens, was ich demnächst
was ich vorhabe ist, für so
Wartezeiten
Wartezeiten wollte ich so eine
so eine extra
so eine extra Scene hier im OBS machen
mit ein bisschen anderem Layout, wo
der Chat in groß drin ist und sowas.
Also jetzt vielleicht nicht
nicht so noch.
Da muss ich den Chat gleich wieder ausblenden, wenn es weiter geht.
In der Beta war es
so höheres Level wie jetzt.
Kann ich,
verstehe ich.
Das ist halt auch ein Game, was eine Weile gespielt hat.
Und deswegen ist es auch so wichtig,
dass der Rank-Modus
was taugt und
dass sowas wie eine Team-Queue kommt, ein Clan-System und sonst was.
Das bringt einfach Motivation.
Overwatch ist ein Team-Game.
Das muss gefördert werden.
Little Samsung, es hat nicht jeder den Chat offen.
Zum Beispiel Leute, die auf dem Smartphone gucken.
Da kannst du auch den Chat aufmachen,
aber die wenigsten haben es im Vollbild mit Chat auf.
Dante fragt,
was hältst du von Destiny 2?
Habe ich keine Meinung zu.
Ich habe mal ein bisschen gespielt.
War genauso wenig mein Fall wie Destiny 1.
Aber Eax, spielst du das noch?
Was denn?
Destiny 2.
Äh, ich habe es,
DLC habe ich vier Stunden gespielt,
dann habe ich es nicht mehr angehört.
Weil du hast ja letztens erzählt,
ihr habt irgendwie Raid gespielt und sowas.
Ja, aber so mittlerweile
ist mir gerade so ein bisschen die Lust vergangen.
Gibt es zu wenig Content?
Ich sag mal so,
wenn du über die Hälfte
bezahlst und dann kriegst du einen Inhalt,
der nicht mal ansatzweise
dem Release nahe kommt.
Hm.
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Ja, ich höre das,
ich höre von vielen Destiny 1 Fans,
also von so richtig Destiny 1.
Komm, ich versuche mal Lucio zu picken,
ob das klappt.
Ich will mal wieder Lucio spielen.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt auch nicht
die neuen Raids oder sowas getestet,
aber mir ist einfach komplett der Reiz.
Haben wir noch eine Mercy hier am Start?
Ja!
Humaniator hat...
Der will nicht?
Was? Die wollen mich auf DPS schicken?
Was ist da los?
Sowas kenne ich gar nicht.
Echt jetzt?
Ja, ich war mal Reaper.
Hätte es Bock gemacht.
Komm, wir probieren das jetzt.
Genau, wir machen jetzt übelst
in your face mit der Shotgun.
Bam, Alter! Bam!
Wir werden gefisst.
Wenn es nicht klappt,
switchen wir aber.
Dann switche ich Mercy rein
und du kannst deinen krassen
Gengu rausholen.
Ich will aber nicht tryharden.
Ja, ja, ja.
Lass mich links durch.
Ja, go.
So, unser Winston liegt schon auf dem Sack.
Warte.
Jetzt.
Ah, ah, Mitte, Mitte, Mitte.
Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe.
Ich bin mit Speed auf dir.
Oh, oh, oh.
Heal, heal, heal, heal.
Speed läuft.
Oh, da fuck.
Nice, nice, nice pick.
Endlich wieder Lucian.
Jawoll, bester Held.
Problem ist, dass Mercy so scheiß OP ist gerade.
Guckt es euch an.
Wir contesten jetzt noch ein bisschen.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Nein, Winston, Winston.
Speed ist an.
Wir haben ein bisschen zu früh gedrückt.
Egal, kommst du raus?
Nee, ich conteste den Scheiß noch ein bisschen.
Okay.
Wir können contesten, das ist gut.
Jedes Prozent, äh, oder auch nicht.
Man kann sagen, jedes Prozent, was wir kriegen, ist gut.
Wollen wir die Leute vom Spawn machen?
Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Machst du Speed?
Ja.
No!
Ich habe Heal laufen.
Speed?
Oh mein Gott, das wird mir auf der Game, wie ich da noch auf die Send daneben schieße.
Ich hole dich ab.
Ich kann vorporten.
Komm, schnell wieder hin.
Die drücken schon wieder.
Gutes Timing, gutes Timing.
So, Soldier oben!
Wir können den Scheiß gut contesten.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Okay, go!
Soldier oben!
Ich geh hoch zum Soldier.
Ich hab den... WTF?
No!
Er ist in der Craft gelandet.
Fuck, kill mich, Alter! Kill mich!
Okay, okay, ich krieg Ulti in der Zeit.
Ich hätte schneller sterben müssen.
Ich bin da.
Ich conteste.
Was?! Was?! Der hatte das noch offen?
Wie lang war denn das High Noon gerade?
Das war vom Respawn bis zum Sp...
Hä?
Oder hab ich jetzt...
Ich hab das einfach nicht gecheckt.
Wie lang der das hatte.
Ja, ich...
Komm.
Lass mal switchen.
Wir brauchen OP Mercy.
Ja, so geht's mir auch.
Ich hab keinen Bock auf Mercy, Chat.
Aber ich muss.
Ich will eigentlich überhaupt kein DPS stoppen gerade.
Es ist...
Swindler ist gut...
Ja, McCree geht auf jeden Fall.
Geht rein.
3...
2...
1...
Capture the Objective.
We got 5 Tanks, so...
Hit the und DPS in the back.
Heute ist so ein Tag, wo ich einfach auch mal auf halber Arschbacke zocken will.
Auch einfach mal Mercy.
Ja, das können wir mal machen, dann.
Dann spiel ich Tank.
Sag mal.
Ich hab klar Ulti.
Alter, der Typ soll mal die Fresse halten.
Wie viel da zu heilen ist, ey.
Guck dir das mal an.
Fuck.
Ich hab ja keinen Ratz mehr.
Ich muss mich verstecken.
Wenn ihr was killt, kann ich Ratz nicht.
Komm runter.
Ich muss den Typen muten.
Der geht mir mega auf den Sack.
Der geht mir mega auf den Sack, ey.
Ja, super.
Sahe vollgefahren.
Gefeedet.
Guck mal.
Jetzt ist er da allein drin.
Was will der denn da eigentlich?
Was will der?
Soll ich da jetzt mit reinhüpfen?
Mich killen lassen?
So sieht es dann aus.
Mein Gott, ey.
Was Leute.
Es gibt kein Spiel, was so hard hiltet wie Overwatch.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Was war das für ein Jump?
Ein Jump in High Ground komplett außerhalb Line of Sight.
Komplett back.
Guck dir den an, da vorne.
Was macht der denn da alleine?
Go, go, jetzt.
Easy, easy win.
Der Typ.
Das ist so geil.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice Pick.
Das war's.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao.
So.
Ich kann es nicht mehr.
Damlich erretzt von mir.
Ich bin schon wieder so krass getiltet bei dem Scheiß Gelaber.
Ich hätte vor, ich hätte eigentlich gleich Valk tüten sollen als ich da oben draufgestanden
hat.
Aber mich fanden so Hirn Nostanks übelst ab.
Was will der eigentlich?
Der springt von hier da oben rein, dass kann doch keiner da hinterher was.. was denkt
der sich denn?
Und unten alle verrecken in der zwischenzeit.
Ow.
Oh่å stomach.
ich dachte es ist längst vorbei ich habe jetzt gar nicht hingeguckt
soll ich da weitermachen dafür ist der non-ultra absolut useless nein das ist überhaupt nicht also
dass ich da jetzt die tracer versucht habe zu retten mitten im kampf war bescheid ich hätte
wald zünden sollen aber also weil gedanke dabei war wir gewinnen den fight jetzt wenn ich die
tracer so rätsel habe ich war für nächsten fall weil wir haben waren so weit hinten dran dass wir
jede und gebraucht hätten wahrscheinlich hätten wir sonst verloren mercys rätsel überhaupt nicht
muss es gibt ja einige falls sie sind auch ein bisschen länger gezogen und sowas und wenn du
halt schaffst einzugreifen bist du gleich wieder ein spieler mehr das ist gut ich meine ist das
op ist da an der ganzen geschichte aber auch der retz an sich ist nicht schlecht ich nerv das mercy
meter auch hardcore zumal ich mercy spiele
ich wollte nie mercy spielen immer davor gedrückt aber jetzt kommt man nicht mehr daran vorbei
ich habe irgendwas überlesen dem tv was hältst du vom upgrade 4930 k zu 8700 k bei den so krass
unschlüssig würde ich noch nicht machen das ist auch ein sechskerner das ding das ist zwar so
sagen wir mal wahrscheinlich in irgendeinen benchmark ein drittel drittel langsamer oder
so. Aber das reicht noch dicke
für aktuelle Games.
Ich sehe da jetzt überhaupt keine Notwendigkeit
für da zu
upgraden.
Wenn du nicht gerade Puppke spielen willst.
Das was überall ruckelt.
Inosaki sagt, ich wäre sehr für ein
Rank Reset, aber davon hält Blizzard nix.
Ich bin da hin und her gerissen bei einem Rank Reset.
Also warum
Blizzard davon nix hält, kann ich verstehen.
Blizzards
größtes Ziel ist ja
den
Lootbox kaufenden Casual
zu fördern.
Und der ist angepisst.
Wenn auf einmal zu viel gute Leute
die mittlerweile nicht mehr auf seinem Rang sind
jetzt wieder auf seinem Rang sind und er einfach
gefistet wird.
Da hat er keinen Bock drauf.
Aber ich bin auch ein bisschen hin und her gerissen zwischen Rank Reset.
Weil aktuell ist es einfach
der Hardcore Grind
also Solo Queue
ist der Hardcore Grind
da habe ich
dass das so random ist.
Du kannst dann auch mal 8 in Folge verlieren.
Kannst auch 8 in Folge gewinnen.
Klar, das ist in jedem Matchmaking System so.
Problem ist, dass in Overwatch die Matches zum größten Teil nicht ausgeglichen sind.
Habt ihr jetzt ja auch gesehen.
Die ersten 3 Matches haben wir die Gegner weggefickt.
Letztes Game wurden wir weggefickt.
Aber
es ist schon mal ein großer Schritt, wenn
dieses Performance Base SR rauskommt.
Aber ich sehe eigentlich da nur
auf dauernde Zukunft für Overwatch.
Wie gesagt, sagte ich mal das alles zu schwarz oder so.
Aber
wenn das komplett überarbeitet wird
und nicht nur
ich meine damit nicht nur das Matchmaking.
Das komplette Ranked.
Also mit Team Queue, mit Clan System, mit allem dabei.
Was einfach motiviert im Team zu spielen.
Zusammen zu spielen, sich zusammen zu verbessern.
Und eben Overwatch so zu spielen wie es gedacht ist.
Weil der Witz ist ja
Quickplay
Quickplay kann man nicht Spiel nennen.
Quickplay ist ähm
weiß gar nicht wie
Wie umschreibt man am besten Quickplay in Overwatch?
Das ist ähm
Das hat mit Overwatch nichts zu tun.
Das ist so ein
Das ist so quasi ein Team Deathmatch mit Klassen.
Oh die haben Orisa.
Oh und Roadhog, ich habe einen Schiss.
Fuck, jetzt kann ich nicht rein.
Ich war nicht so über uns.
Oben?
Ja.
Könnte da mal irgendjemand drauf?
Kein Bock.
Was ist denn das hier?
Da interessiert sich keiner für. Ich kann da nichts machen.
Zumindest nicht.
Ich hüpfe da jetzt rein.
Ich mache da jetzt YOLO.
Kommt zurück Leute, kommt zurück.
Ne, das klappt so nicht.
So, da switchen wir jetzt mal.
Was switchen wir da?
Wir switchen mal
einen Tank mit Shit.
Ich weiß es
bestimmt immer noch oben.
Bestimmt.
Ich hatte es einmal halb tot, wenn da nur einer mit drauf gegangen wäre.
Nice Firestrike-Hit.
Nice so, nice so, nice so.
Sind wir, komm. Ja, Tracer ist immer noch hinter uns, klar.
Wie soll das auch anders sein?
Oh, huge.
Crap.
Haha, die wollen, oh Gott ey.
Okay, wenn wir jetzt schnell sind,
haben wir den easy den Punkt. Wir sind schneller.
Aber nicht allein.
Leute, ihr müsst kurz verzögern.
Kannst du mich kurz herfliegen lassen?
Passt.
Ich charge jetzt.
Roadhog, Punkt.
Okay, wir gehen jetzt da mit 2 Ulz rein.
Okay, wir gehen Main.
Fuck, Leute, wo seid ihr denn?
Die Moira, ey.
Fuck.
Sie hat recht geschildert.
Ja, das ist das
Problem an Mainrush.
Ne, Winston.
Winston.
Und am besten ist, immer gleich in den Chat
schreiben, was andere schlecht machen.
Das ist das allerwichtigste in Overwatch.
Ja.
Das können sie alle.
Was ist denn jetzt da?
Ist die Tracer hinter uns, kann das sein?
Ja, ja, die Tracer ist hinter uns.
Wir haben, wir haben da halt nichts dagegen.
Easy.
Ich hüpfe da jetzt rein.
Ich hüpfe da nicht rein.
Das ist so lächerlich.
Du, wir müssen da irgendwas anderes machen.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Ähm.
Das geht nicht.
Hm.
Die Tracer fickt uns komplett.
Unser McCree müsste mal stunnen.
Irgendwas halt, wir müssen mal umkippen.
Die kippt nie um.
Oh Mann, jetzt deckern sie wieder da vorne, ey.
Ich mach's, ich klein mit uninstalled.
Das ist so, es gibt nichts, kein Game,
was so krass tilt wie Overwatch.
Hey Leute, was war das denn für eine Flashbring von McCree?
So, jetzt aber. Kommt Leute, kommt.
Go.
Und da stirbt wieder einer.
Warum?
Weil Moira wahrscheinlich nicht geheilt hat.
Weiß, weiß es nicht.
Okay, go, go.
Mercy ist down fast.
Okay.
Ich hüpfe jetzt hoch.
Runter, runter, runter, runter.
Hau ab, McCree.
Spast.
Verpiss dich, Alter.
Wir werden so krass gefickt von der einen Tracer.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Das hatten wir.
Hey, die tun ja noch Flashbang.
Genau, so sieht's aus.
Sind wir alle da?
Ah, meine Güte.
Okay, äh.
Was kann ich denn machen?
Diva.
Mir fällt das, ehrlich gesagt,
grad nicht ein.
Ein Flashbang, ein Hook.
Wir haben alles, was du gegen eine Tracer machen kannst.
Wir haben einen Sniper.
Ja, wir müssen durch die Mitte.
Ja.
Okay.
Schnell, schnell. Weg, weg, weg.
So.
Erinnert ihr euch noch, was ich euch gesagt habe,
was das Problem an Overwatch-Matchmaking ist?
Du wirst 40% weggefickt,
40% fickst du die Gegner weg, 20% sind gute Matches.
Hier sehen wir jetzt das zweite
Wir-werden-weggefickt-des-Tages.
Der Arme hier, wird er geflamed.
Zurecht.
Also, ich spiel keinen Reinhardt.
Ich kann keinen Reinhardt spielen dagegen.
Es kommt keiner mit der Tracer klar.
Was spiel ich denn am besten?
Ich hab echt keine Ahnung, Leute.
Ich hab wirklich keinen blassen Schimmer,
was spielen soll.
Komm, wir machen jetzt Support-Duo.
Ich, ich, ich balle die Tracer.
Easy.
Was machst du in Overwatch, um nicht zu tilten?
Hört sich das an,
dass du die Tracer nicht tilten kannst?
Sieht das so an, als hätte ich da irgendwie einen Plan,
wie das geht gerade?
Ich tilte.
Natürlich, was sonst?
Was ist das für dich momentan beste Multiplayer-Spiel,
was langfristig Motivation bietet?
Das wüsste ich gerne.
Hallo, Renoto.
Wenn das so weitergeht, ist Overwatch
Mitte 2018
RIP.
Man muss sich mal vorstellen,
Blizzard hat bis heute nicht anerkannt,
dass die Spawns bei 2CP vielleicht
ein bisschen dumm sind.
Vielleicht Siege.
Ja, vielleicht Siege.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Die D.Va ist da
in der Infants Pass.
Oh, meine Güte.
Jetzt guckst du die ganze Zeit an,
so am Fenster?
Und was war es?
Ja, Marvin, ich sehe das ähnlich.
Also vor allem MMOs
ist für Langzeit eigentlich das Beste.
Ich habe gleich Ulti.
WTF, wie kann man da jetzt schon sterben,
bevor da eigentlich ein Gage kommt?
Ich bin oben gestunt.
Tot.
Komm runter.
Das können wir halten,
wir haben einen Pick.
Ich habe gleich Ulti, 4%.
Lass mich euch heilen!
Das war zwar ein bisschen
der meiste Trance, aber man weiß ja nie.
Man weiß ja nie.
Ich glaube, wenn du nicht drauf gegangen wärst, hätten wir jetzt verloren.
Ja, deswegen
habe ich auch nochmal getranced.
Moment, war das jetzt
ein zweiter Tick oder was?
Oh Gott, guck mal, die müssen den Millimeter capturen!
Na, wenn du so weit hinten dran bist,
bleibt dir nichts übrig,
wie das safe zu machen oder auf Risiko
zu spielen.
In dem Fall dachte ich mir, verlieren?
Besser als nicht verlieren.
Der Hanzo ist halt so krass angekontestet.
Ich kann da nichts gegen machen.
Ich brauch das Schild.
Der muss jetzt gefickt werden da draußen.
Ah, richtig.
Okay, jetzt ist es nicht so weit.
So, nice.
Vier Minuten, ey. Vier Minuten.
Ich glaube, die gehen oben links.
Oh, scheinbar.
Der Hanzo ist fast tot.
Da kommt ein Roadhog.
Point, point, point, point.
Gebadet von der Tracer.
Ich gehe wieder oben links.
Oben links war noch ein Roadhog.
Ich hör den, ich hör den laufen.
Ah, der ist unserer.
Der muss doch sterben, Alter.
So, ich hab Ulti.
Oh, oh.
Drauf, drauf, drauf, drauf.
Leute, wir können nicht die Trans verschenken.
Okay, wir gehen nicht drauf.
Doch, können wir.
Wir haben zwei auf dem Spot und...
Oh, scheiße.
Ich spamm da jetzt einfach mal rein.
Naja, wenigstens ist die Ulti da oben
und nicht auf dem Spot.
Das war's.
Wenn wir jetzt nicht noch ein, zwei Picks kriegen...
So, um meine Theorie...
Pass auf.
...weiter zu bestätigen.
Nice Mercy Ult.
Es sind immer alle...
Immer sind die anderen dran schuld.
Schreckt.
Yeah.
Er hat doch schon...
Der ist doch schon gelieft.
Moin.
Mockingjay und Crazy C.
Damietv.
Honto Trio, please.
Hahaha.
Anything could reduce
arts of insanity.
Hahaha.
Nein.
Habe ich schon
das Match angefasst? Ja.
Das ist das Schlimme.
Aber Leute, es ist genauso, wie ich es am Anfang
beschrieben habe, das Matchmaking.
Wenn du drei Games Gegner zerstörst,
wo du, du konntest quasi Nase bohren
in den ersten drei Games,
trifft's, glaube ich, ganz gut, oder?
Also, ich habe die ersten drei Games nicht gespielt, so.
Ja, ich auch, gefühlt.
Ich bin ein bisschen mit Winston rumgestanden, easy bin.
Und die letzten zwei Games waren einfach
nahezu hoffnungslos.
Das frustriert halt.
Ich glaube, das
Verlieren an sich frustriert gar nicht so sehr.
Sondern einfach, wie die Matches laufen.
Und oftmals so das Gefühl,
du hast keinen Einfluss drauf.
Ich meine, Fakt ist,
du hast immer Einfluss drauf.
Die Frage ist halt,
ob's reicht.
Soll ich Q nochmal?
Max, du brauchst Monka Shake, Monka Gun.
Ähm,
ich habe Monka Shake drinnen gehabt,
das habe ich rausgeworfen für Easy Clap.
Wurde Soldier genervt?
Nein.
Aber ein Soldier hat sich schon ewig nichts mehr getan.
Ich spiele jetzt
keine Mercy.
Keine Sand oder sowas.
Da wird jetzt
raufgesprungen und gereckt.
Wie alt bist du, Max?
33.
Was spielen denn die anderen so?
Der
Boob Smasher 3
hat 21 Stunden Mercy,
13 Stunden Mei.
Und der
Bronze Player
hat Moira und Genji
und Mercy.
Du hast den hier Held weggenommen,
die wissen nicht, was ich spielen soll.
Mir egal.
Ja, ich sag's ja nur.
Ich sag's ja nur.
Nee, nee, Marvin, man hat 5 Plätze
bei der Twitch-TV.
Ich hab 0-3-D.
Wenn wir jetzt den Attack-Turb kriegen...
Kann funktionieren.
Vorhin sind wir auch mit Symmetra durchgekommen.
Du weißt doch, wie's ist.
Vorher war das sogar
so krass unbalanced, dass wir
Symmetra die Gegner
komplett zermatscht haben.
Ich glaub,
beim Diven wird's ein bisschen schwer.
Ich weiß nicht, was die Mei vorhat.
Aber ich glaub, die will eine Ball setzen.
Guck mal, wir haben eine T-Mobile, das könnte jetzt schon funktionieren.
Ja, Inosaki, das ist echt
das Problem.
Das Verlieren ist, glaub ich, gar nicht so das Problem.
Sondern wie die Matches
gestaltet sind.
Oh, da geht's jetzt volle rein.
Oh, Junkrat.
Ich brauch Heal.
Ich will da nicht schon rein.
Sam, heil mich doch mal.
Ich hätte eigentlich mit der D.Va
da helfen müssen, aber ich hab die Mercy fast.
Mercy, Mercy, Mercy, die ist low.
Fuck, ich bin in der...
Alter, wieviel Damage
die Phaser macht. Und das auf übelste
Distanzen.
Jolo-Affe mach ich jetzt.
Jolo-Affe.
Ich hüpfe mal weg.
Ich push mal ein bisschen mit.
Hier im Haus ist irgendwas
gewesen grad.
Was? Der Junkrat!
Junkrat ist im Haus. Er ist fast tot.
Kann nicht hinterher.
Hinter mir, hinter mir.
Oh Gott.
Der Schuss war gut.
Lade mal den Chat
neu. Ich hab den Chat wieder ausgeblendet.
Ach so,
ihr meint euch untereinander.
Dann vergesst's.
Distan macht auf Range ganz gut Damage.
Aber so auf mittlere.
NEIN!
Verträgtes Kackschild, ey.
Ich bin drauf.
Ist das ein Pharah-One-Track oder
Wappen switcht der nicht?
Weiß nicht.
Nö, gar nicht mal.
Jetzt kann er sich halt hübsch abschminken,
dass ich mit dem fliegen gehe gegen den Widowmaker.
Linke Seite.
Au.
Ready?
Ja.
Ich geh gleich hoch.
Das ist so krass, Junkrat.
Das ist so krasse Scheiße, ey.
Leute, wo seid ihr denn?
Def.
Nervt's grad einfach nur das Game, ey.
Unsere Widow ist, glaub ich,
aft.
Waren auch ein paar dämliche Jumps grad.
Wenn ich die getroffen wär,
wären sie tot gewesen.
Hu hu hu hu hu hu
hu.
Der nächste.
Okay, go go.
Massi, massi, massi, massi, massi.
Jawoll, jetzt.
Nein.
Haha, ich dachte, ich komm noch zurück.
Hahaha.
Du kannst ja mal probieren.
So, ähm.
Schlimmer ist,
dass die Leute nicht reagieren, ne.
Weil schon so zwei wichtige Positionen
gekillt worden sind.
Go, go.
Hätten wir jetzt mal Speed.
Und dann ist so was wie Junkrat im Spiel.
Ich hab den Tire gar nicht gehört.
Ich hab nur gehört, wie die ganze Zeit Ultis
gezogen worden sind.
Tire schon gehört, aber...
Was soll ich denn machen?
Oh, wir haben Pick.
Sind die oben?
Was sind denn die?
Ja, ich bin auf der Mercy.
Ja, klasse, kannst raus.
Wo sind denn alle?
Gut.
Achtung.
Das Schlimme ist,
wir müssen jetzt rein, sonst...
Wir müssen, ja.
Liest Marks Chat, klar.
Spätestens nach der Runde.
Naja.
Also nach der Runde Schluss.
Vergiss es ja.
Ja.
Welches Level ist Widow?
Keine Ahnung.
Können wir mal gucken.
So.
Jetzt spiel ich mal einen Held, auf den ich Bock hab.
Scheiß drauf.
Äh, dann mach ich Forrester.
Ne, komm, lass...
Jetzt soll jemand anderes Mercy spielen.
Ich hab die Wochen gehandelt.
Ich hab keinen Bock.
Doch, da hat einer 6 Stunden Mercy-Playtime.
Ja, wir haben zwei Mercy-Mains.
Ich hab doch vorhin nachgeguckt.
Der Bronze...
Der Bronze-Player kann spielen.
Und der Boop-Smasher.
Wenn er möchte.
Will er aber nicht.
Wollen wir jetzt Solo-Heal?
Ah, Moira.
Bässe, Bässe.
Natürlich schon.
Hast du eigentlich an deinem Tool weitergearbeitet?
Nein.
Ist halt absolutes räudiges Setup, ne?
Ich hab schon Schlimmeres gesehen
und mit Schlimmeren gewonnen.
Ja, erste Runde zum Beispiel.
Attack-Symmetra. Easy.
Genau das.
Weiß ja nicht, vielleicht
kackt der der Gegner jetzt auch total ab in der Attack.
Ich glaub's zwar nicht,
aber wir sehen's gleich.
Ich hab jetzt ja viel
gemeckert diesen Stream
über alles
an Overwatch und drumherum.
Ich glaub, wenn man's ganz simpel
zusammenfassen will, ist,
dass es auf Dauer so einfach keinen Spaß macht.
Hanzo, ist das der Erste,
der auf den Sack kriegt?
Ja.
Oh, Widow Main.
Ich bin fast tot.
Ich brauch Heal.
Sollen die kommen?
Hanzo, komm her.
Hanzo.
Fuck.
Hätte ja klappen können.
Sleeped. Wird natürlich direkt aufgeweckt.
Perfekt.
Oh, oh, ich bin fast down.
Leicht so, leicht so, leicht so.
Rekt!
Ist über uns was?
Rechts ist ein Junkrat drinne.
Äh, ich muss nachladen.
Ich muss nachladen.
Aber ich bin ja auch der einzige Heiler.
Auf, geh raus.
Nice, nice, go, go, go, go.
Go!
Geschreckt.
Und ja, Chet, mir ist klar,
dass Ana nicht optimal ist.
Ich hab jede Runde dieses Roman Held gespielt,
bis auf dieses eine King of the Hill.
Eine Runde von Lucio, wo ich Bock drauf hatte.
Und die letzten drei Runden
hatten wir nur Leute, die gesagt haben,
scheiß auf Team, ich spiele, was ich Bock hab,
dann mach ich das jetzt mal die letzte Runde auch.
Die letzte halbe Runde.
Und ich kann nicht reported werden,
das ist das Beste, oder?
Weil ich throwe nicht.
Ich spiele nur einen Helm, der gerade scheiße ist.
Könnte dem Winston noch mal einer Damage machen?
Ich kann nicht mal nichts machen,
gescheit.
Ah.
Ist Lucios Heal nicht so stark?
Nee.
Ah gut, ich hätte eben nach unten gucken können.
Mr. Samu, ja, du kannst jeden Held spielen,
aber es ist nicht jeder Held, äh,
unbedingt viable gerade.
Stano booste dich jetzt.
Hinter uns Roadhog!
Oh!
Na fuck!
Er hat auch den Füß durchgeschossen.
Es gibt keinen Heal.
Es sei denn, die Moira ist mal so nett.
Und heilt euch.
Spawnway vom Hansu.
Max, was hältst du von Bastion?
Extrem gut auf manchen Maps.
Ohne Kappa.
Wirklich extrem.
Wir müssen, wir müssen contesten.
Ich komm raus.
Huge Shatter.
Hat nix getroffen.
Alle purple.
Ich muss nachladen.
Alt! Junkrat ist so ein dummer Held.
Ich habe gerade 370 HP instant verloren.
Danke Junkrat.
Junkrat.
Egal.
So, Schluss für heute.
3-3.
Drei Matches, Gegner übelst gerackt.
Drei Matches
gerackt worden.
Overwatch-Mech making ranked
at its finest.
Das ist grazile Movement.
Rekt.
Moment, warum ist das nicht der Tireplay of the Game?
Sollte er eigentlich ja sein.
Was war jetzt da dran?
Day of the Game.
Ne.
Ich spiel jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich denke mal bis Season Ende werde ich jetzt auch nicht mehr spielen.
Ich krieg Anfälle.
Zuckung.
So, wen hosten wir, Leute?
Wen hosten wir?
Ich hoste meinen Lieblings-Streamer.
Hat zwar 4000 Zuschauer.
Aber.
Muss sein.
Follow Grubby.
Ich guck mir das so gerne an.
Ich bin gespannt dazu zu gucken.
Ich spiel zwar Heroes of the Storm,
ein Game was ich nicht spiele.
Du guckst den auch ab und zu, oder?
Mhm.
Wenn ich seinen Stream gucke,
dann hab ich auch Bock auf Warcraft 3
und Heroes of the Storm.
Ich spiel weder das eine noch das andere.
Aber.
Ja, Heroes of the Storm ist halt auch so.
Ich guck ihm einfach gerne zu.
Also Heroes
hat nicht gerade den Eindruck gemacht,
dass es irgendwie besser ist als Overwatch.
Heroes hat jetzt Performance-Based-Match
SR eingeführt.
Hab ich gelesen.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie sie es da gemacht haben.
Da stelle ich mir es ähnlich
schwierig zuvor, Performance zu tracken
wie in Overwatch.
Gibt es da auch Mercy mittlerweile?
Ich glaube Mercy nicht, aber es gibt sauvieler.
Es gibt Hanzo, Genji,
Zarya, Tracer.
Ne, ich wollte bloß einen Bezug auf den Rival fokussieren.
Ich überleg grad.
Leute, wisst ihr, was für Overwatch-Helden
in Heroes of the Storm gerade sind?
Genji, Hanzo, Tracer, Zarya,
Lucio,
ähm
Lootboxen. Ja, Lootboxen kann ich noch machen.
Hab ich noch weiter? Lootbox noch.
Jawoll.
Legendary Torbjörn!
Torbjörn!
Der Legendary Torbjörn-Skin.
Paveloyman sagt, ich hatte vergessen,
dass Hotz existiert.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht.
Mich nervt's,
wie schaut's denn aus?
Hast du Bock auf Rainbow Six?
Ja, aber nicht on stream.
Das können wir ja auch offline
zocken oder so.
Ja, wir müssen uns das erstmal in Ruhe angucken.
Was ihr wissen müsst,
von wegen Rainbow Six,
der E-Ax ist der übelste Rainbow Six Pro.
Beziehungsweise wahrer.
Ging voll ab.
Am Anfang, ne?
Wie lange hast du gespielt?
Also aktiv mit Clan und so?
Oder was heißt Clan? Orga!
Merkt man das ja.
Also mit Orga war relativ schnell.
Ich glaube, ich hatte gerade mal 30 Stunden im Game.
Dann war ich bei
Pentasports in der Community.
Und
kurz darauf,
keine Ahnung, so drei Wochen später oder so,
hat sich das neue Team gebildet.
Dann wurde gereckt.
Das ging ganz gut.
Ja, dann spielen wir off stream.
Zumindest in die ersten paar Runden,
wenn ich ein bisschen Plan von dem Game hab.
Ne, ich hab's jetzt gestern
nochmal gezockt und so.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, hab mich begeistert.
Also jetzt so von
der Hittrick scheint es besser zu sein.
Nice.
Zumindest ist nichts negatives aufgefallen.
Vorerst.
Ja, wir können uns das mal ein bisschen angucken.
Vielleicht ist es ja ein Game, was mich packt.
Ich hab's ja nur in der Beta mal kurz ausprobiert.
Mal gucken.
Aber auf Dauer
ist es einfach zu
nervenaufreibend.
Und du hast ja auch das Gefühl, du hast nichts,
es hat nichts gebracht zu spielen.
Das ist auch ein doofes Gefühl.
Ne, wir haben doch gerade wieder
dasselbe Rating, wie wir angefangen haben.
Ja, ungefähr.
Ich glaub sogar ein bisschen weniger.
Weniger als wir angefangen haben.
Obwohl, 3-3.
Fortnite hat mich nicht gepackt.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab Fortnite nie gespielt.
Wenn du halt quasi jetzt
sechs Matches in Anführungsstrichen
ultra getryhardet hast,
ich mein, es geht noch härter.
Du kannst auch 110% geben.
Allerdings kannst du das halt auch nicht permanent.
Und...
Du hast halt das Gefühl,
es war umsonst.
Gar nicht durch SR, weil die Matches halt so sinnlos waren.
Es war heute nicht
ein schönes Match dabei.
Es waren dreimal Gegner weggefistet
und dreimal weggefistet worden.
Es ist einfach...belanglos.
So.
Und dann hat sich noch einer das XQC tiltet
und ab und zu mal ein bisschen
nicht so tryhard spielt.
Und dann kommen die Justice Warrior
auf Reddit
und regen sich auf.
Ich kann verstehen, warum Taimo zum Beispiel
nicht mal streamt und...
Tja.
Er hat übrigens letztens auch was cooles gesagt
und streamt.
Konnte ich mich echt mit identifizieren.
Taimo hat letztens im Stream gesagt,
von 100% der Zeit, wo er Overwatch gespielt hat,
hat er ein Drittel Spaß.
Und...
Das wird sich wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil auf organisiert
im Team beziehen.
Und nicht unbedingt auf den Rest.
Wie findest du den zweiten
Zelda Breath of the Wild DLC?
Habe ich nicht gespielt.
Genau, Crazy's Events. Wenigstens gute Matches.
Ich glaube, das Verlieren tiltet gar nicht
so hart. Klar, jeder
jeder gewinnt lieber als
er verliert. Das ist in jedem Game so.
Das ist sogar in Call of Duty Team Deathmatch
im Endeffekt so. Jeder will am Ende
der Runde stehen haben, Victory oder
Team One oder was auch immer.
Aber das wäre gar nicht so schlimm.
Ist Master in Overwatch vergleichbar
mit Master in LoL? Ich habe keine Ahnung, was
Master in LoL ist.
Master ist der zweithöchste Rang.
Aber ehrlich, die Ränge in Overwatch...
Die Ränge in Overwatch
sind dafür, dass sich die Leute gut fühlen.
Nicht wirklich was zu repräsentieren.
Das einzige, was was aussagt,
ist im Endeffekt GM, beziehungsweise
sagen wir mal, was so richtig was aussagt,
ist eigentlich Top 200.
Der Rest ist so...
Du meinst, wenn da die 48 Win-Welt-Mercies
drin sind? Ja, leider.
Leider.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Also ich finde
momentan die Ränge sind alle nichts aussagend.
Zumal in der EU
eigentlich auch nicht. Haben wir überhaupt noch
Profi-Spieler hier?
War ganz blöd gefragt.
Ich überleg gerade.
Weil früher
Season 1, Season 2 war sowas ja so.
Tific und Konsorten sind jetzt ja sogar
in NA.
Ja.
Was ist da los? Season 1, Season 2.
Je höher du gekommen bist, umso wahrscheinlicher war es,
dass du gegen Pro spielen musstest.
Entsprechend ist es auch.
Aber wir hatten so geile Matches erste Season.
So ein halbes Premier-Team
von uns, ein halbes Premier-Team mit Tific
und sonst wären wir noch dabei.
Sogar ein Match mit Tific
und Forzen. Weißt du, auf
Panamura haben wir sie gereckt.
Ja.
Aber
es ist anscheinend vorbei.
Ich finde mir
also so persönlich finde ich halt,
mir fehlt jetzt mittlerweile echt die Challenge,
dass du das Game zu zocken weißt.
Im Prinzip ist jeder Rang fast schon das gleiche.
Es fehlt einfach so die treibende
Motivation dahinter.
Wenn, überleg dir mal, du hättest,
es gäbe wirklich, wir haben ja letztens schon drüber geredet.
Stell dir mal vor, es gäbe wirklich
sowas wie den Clan-System, was ja schon mal
geteased wurde oder zumindest gab es dann in
Battle.net Threat dazu,
wo du dir, ich mein, es ist utopisch
anzunehmen, dass quasi Leute
komplett immer im exakt festen
Six-Deck spielen können, die halt
noch was anderes zu tun haben als Overwatch.
Ja. Deswegen ist ein Clan-System
eigentlich wäre das ne super Sache. Du machst
dir nen Clan auf mit sagen wir 10 Leuten drin
und du spielst
und du wirst halt quasi
wie eine Einheit geratet.
Wenn du halt mit Leuten spielst, die deutlich
schlechter sind als andere, dann ist das dein
Fail, dann hast du halt Pech,
hast dir die falschen Mitspieler ausgesucht.
Das macht das Ranking auch viel einfacher.
Du kannst Team A als Einheit
werten und Team B als Einheit werten.
Vor allem auch immer, als
immer die gleiche Einheit.
So, und
wenn man dann, dann hätte es auch einen gewissen
Stellenwert, wenn du sagst, hey
das ist, das ist GM-Clan
oder wie auch immer.
Hm. Du könntest
automatische, du könntest automatische
In-Game-Tournaments machen,
dass du sagst, hey,
du machst jetzt quasi,
du machst jetzt hier ein automatisch
generiertes Tournament, kannst du dich anmelden, einmal
am Wochenende oder zweimal am Wochenende, Samstag, Sonntag
gibt es halt
zur Primetime, gibt es ein automatisch
generiertes Turnier.
Du kannst auch das Leute ohne Probleme casten
lassen und sowas auf, müssen sich
halt vorher registrieren. Könntest du dich
als Clan anmelden für das
Turnier. Du könntest
sogar ne, dann in der Profilseite des Clans
gucken so nach dem Motto, geplaced, Top 3
sowieso, Weekly, sonstwas.
Dann machst du halt deine Weekly Turniere, dann
machst du vielleicht nochmal ein Monthly,
ein organisiertes Turnier, mit
jemandem das organisiert,
dahinter, und
was gecastet wird
und sonstwas. Du könntest so viel schöne
Dinger machen, wenn
du sie machen würdest.
Es mangelt ja nicht an Ideen
für das Game.
Ich weiß nicht, woran es bei Blizzard mangelt,
ob, ob sie nicht
wollen. Also sprich,
ob sie denken, sie wissen es wirklich besser
und belehren uns vielleicht eines
Tages, dass wir alle falsch gelegen
haben.
Oder
sie sind sich zu fein, sich
Sachen abzugucken, die woanders funktionieren.
Ich weiß
es nicht. Ich kann es mir nicht erklären.
Ist ja
ansonsten, es wird ja immer
ganz gerne drauf rumgehackt, so nach dem Motto,
es hört keiner, also die Entwickler
hören nicht auf die Spieler und sowas in der Richtung.
Ich sag ja sonst auch immer, natürlich hören
die auf die Spieler, die hören sich an, was die Spieler wollen
und wägen das dann ab.
Ich mein, es ist kostenloses Feedback im Endeffekt.
Aber
ich habe hier wirklich
so meine Zweifel. Ich weiß nicht.
Kusswort
sagt, das werden die aber nicht
machen, denke ich, weil 90%
das Spiel Casual spielen.
Ich weiß nicht, wo das herkommt.
Ich kann es weder
widerlegen noch belegen,
dass 90% das Spiel Casual ist.
Meine Erfahrung mit Quickplay in letzter Zeit war,
dass die Queue Times ziemlich hoch sind,
für Quickplay, wenn auch da angeblich
so viele mehr Leute sind, wie in Rank,
und das Quickplay durch und durch voll mit Smurfs ist.
Also von den vielen Spielern
im Quickplay sehe ich da auch nichts.
Zumal man sagen muss,
Quickplay hat mit Overwatch nichts zu tun.
Es ist Overwatch.
Es findet in Overwatch statt,
aber es hat mit Overwatch,
wie Overwatch gedacht ist.
Und bin ich mir ziemlich sicher,
dass es eine der größten
dass Blizzard sich das so gedacht hat
bei einem teambasierten Spiel, wie es
gespielt werden soll, halt eben im Team
und das ist Quickplay nicht
By the way, ähm
morgen kommt ja ein PUBG raus, ne
also falls du dein Geld zurückhaben möchtest
kannst du morgen machen
Äh, ach es erscheint jetzt wirklich, ja
Jaja, ich geb's direkt zurück
Hahaha
Direkt, ähm
Aha, hab ich gar nicht mitgerichtet
Ähm, ich hab da so meine Zweifel
ob die Performance jetzt besser ist, so
Ja, also nachdem
das ist ja gerade der Testclient
auf den Servern drauf, ne, das ist ja das
was jetzt released wird und das ist halt
totaler Abfall, das ist keine 1.0, das ist 0.1
Ja, das ist
das ist wieder ein komplett anderes Thema für sich
jetzt hab ich mich ja erstmal jetzt hier nochmal
eine halbe Stunde über Overwatch ausgekotzt
Ja, kannst du bei PUBG weiterkotzen
Jetzt könnte ich bei PUBG weitermachen, oder was
Das wäre eine Idee, ne
Ja, Pathfinder und Man, das
ist das Problem, ich denke, das funktioniert nicht
Du kannst nicht auf beiden Hochzeiten tanzen
Du kannst kein krass mega Casual Game machen und Competitive
Dass Blizzard Richtung Competitive gehen will, sieht man an der Overwatch League, aber auf
der anderen Seite auch wieder nicht
Ich verstehe die Linie von Blizzard nicht, das ist glaube ich mein
Das, was mir da, wo ich mir da auch so schon oft den Kopf geholt, zerbrochen hab
PUBG ist ein Drecksgame
Du hast jemanden, der gibt morgen auch zurück, wie es aussieht, erks
1.0 Version Kappa
Hahaha
Ich würde nicht so weit gehen und sagen, PUBG ist ein Drecksgame
Ne, an sich ist es ja, dieser Spielgedanke ist ja endgeil, finde ich, macht mir Bock so
Ja, ich kann auch jeden verstehen, der das spannend findet, ja genau
Also, dass man das spannend findet, voll verständlich, ja
Mit der Zeit läufst du halt irgendwann mal gegen diese eine Mauer, wo es nicht mehr weitergeht
Warum geht es nicht weiter?
Weil der Netcode scheiße ist, weil es rockelt und ne, all solche Sachen, das sind halt technische
Limitierungen
Das ist das...
Das ist das größte Problem, was ich bei PUBG sehe und warum ich mir vorstellen könnte,
ist, dass jetzt nicht unbedingt Fortnite, ich habe jetzt in letzter Zeit immer mal wieder
was von Fortnite erzählt, so nach dem Motto Fortnite übertrifft PUBG und sowas
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Fortnite ist, ich könnte mir vorstellen, Fortnite ist auch nicht unbedingt
für jeden was, mit diesem, erstens vom Look her, genau, vom Look her, von diesem Bausystem
und sowas
Ich glaube, das ist nicht jedermanns Sache, ähm, aber ich bin mir sicher, dass...
Das in der Schub...
Das nicht...
Das ist sogar schon aus der Schublade raus
Bei den großen Publishern bei den Entwicklerstudios, da lag in der Schublade Lagenkonzepte für
Battle Royale Spiele und die sind mittlerweile aus der Schublade raus
Haben ein dickes Entwicklerteam hinten dran, ein erfahrenes Studio und die basteln da dran
Und mich würde es nicht wundern
Das können wir clippen und gucken, ob das stimmt.
Wenn wir jetzt sehen, dass wir...
nächstes Jahr Battlefield in Battle-Royale-Modus
hätte.
Ich predikte das jetzt einfach mal.
Also ich würde es abfeiern,
wenn das Waffenhandling noch so anständig
ist. Klippt das,
Leute, und wenn es nächstes Jahr so ist, können wir sagen,
jawohl, wir wussten es
als erstes. Ich predikte jetzt einfach
mal, Battlefield, was welches auch immer es werden
wird, wahrscheinlich ja leider
ein Zweiter-Weltkrieg-Battlefield, doch kein
Bad Company 3 dieses Jahr,
wird einen Battle-Royale-Spiel-Modus haben.
Wie kam das
jetzt? Gab es da wieder
neue Infos? Ja, es gab neue Infos
zu Battlefield, dass
es zwei
Sachen gibt, die in Entwicklung sind. Es ist auch
irgendwie logisch, wenn man sich überlegt, die Typen, die
Hardline gemacht haben, die müssen ja auch was machen, die können nicht
ganz nach Däumchen drehen.
Und anscheinend ist
Bad Company 3, wenn man den Leaks und
Gerüchten glaubt, bei denen in Entwicklung
und DICE kümmert sich, also Schweden,
kümmert sich um
den Nachfolger von Battlefield 1. Also im
Endeffekt bohren sie Battlefield 1 raus und bringen
es wahrscheinlich als Battlefield, wie auch
immer sie es nennen. Ich hoffe nicht Battlefield 2.
Dann ist nämlich die Verwirrung komplett.
Wie dumm
dieser Name ist. Ich könnte mich da Stunden
drüber aufregen, das Ding Battlefield 1
zu nennen. Das ist so dumm.
Ah, es tut weh,
jedes Mal, wenn ich Battlefield 1 ausspreche,
ist das wie, wie wenn dir einer
ein Haar ausreißt.
BF
BF-Royale-Confirmed. Was ist
ein Battle-Royale-Spiel-Modus?
Ich hätte nicht vermutet, dass man das
2K17 erklären muss, aber
es ist eigentlich für dich gut, dass das an dir
vorbeigegangen ist, weil die meisten Spiele bis jetzt
einfach Crap sind.
Im Prinzip ist das eigentlich simpel
erklärt. Das ist ein Last Man Standing
auf einer großen Map.
Mit
ein bisschen King of the Hill, so quasi
eine Zone, die
halt vorgegeben ist,
in der man spielen muss, die sich verändert.
Trifft's doch ganz gut, oder?
Ja.
Macht nix. Ich hab grad versucht
zu erklären, was Battle-Royale ist.
Achso, ja.
Immer kleiner
während der Zone, 100 Leute schlagen sich
den Kopf ein. Ja, genau. Im Prinzip
Last Man Standing auf einer großen Map.
Oder Last
Team Standing, je nachdem, wie man das will.
Ubisoft haut dann auch ein Far Cry
Battle-Royale raus. Leute, mich würde das
nicht wundern. Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn 2018
von
großen Reihen, großen Marken
und auch einfach
nur von großen Herstellern
Battle-Royale-Spiele rauskommen.
Und die werden Pupke
zerschmettern.
Wenn es dahin noch in diesem Zustand ist.
Pupke ist das einzige Spiel,
was es zurzeit gibt, was eben so
mit diesem realistischen Look, was
darauf ausgelegt ist,
was an sich im Kern ja auch spaßig ist
und spannend. Das ist ja auch das, was das Spiel
irgendwie trägt. Aber Pupke hat so
viel krasse technische Probleme
und es ist ja nicht so, dass die Spieler
dann irgendwie dem Spiel treu wären,
so nach dem Motto, es gibt
ein besseres, ich spiele weiter das Schlechtere.
Nö. Sobald es ein besseres gibt, sind die Leute
fort. Und das
lässt sich EA, Activision, Ubisoft
und wie sie nicht alle heißen
und auch andere Entwickler garantiert nicht
entgehen. Das wird 2018
wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen, das
könnte ich mir gut vorstellen zumindest,
so das Battle-Royale-Jahr,
so wie es das MOBA-Jahr
und die MOBA-Jahre gab, wo jeder
ein MOBA entwickelt hat. Gucken wir mal
zu Crytek, lol. Gibt es damit noch nicht.
Eine Weile auch nicht mehr. Aber mich
würde es nicht wundern, wenn das nächste Battle-Royale-Modus
hat. So, jetzt habe ich doch
trotzdem viel länger geschwätzt, als ich eigentlich wollte.
Ja,
Eiskräuter, das ist richtig.
Eiskräuter sagt was
Gutes. Pupke und Fortnite
basieren auf derselben Engine.
Fortnite und
Pupke basieren auf Unreal.
Jetzt dreimal dürft ihr raten,
welche Hersteller mehr Erfahrung mit Unreal
Engine hat.
Ich kann es euch sagen, Bluehole ist es nicht.
Ja, wobei ich finde,
das andere, das Fortnite
läuft ja auch nicht so viel besser.
Also wenn man sich mal anguckt, was
da Streamer teilweise für High-End-Maschinen
haben und FPS
teilweise trotzdem unter 100.
Ich habe es nicht ausprobiert. Man muss ja auch sagen, Unreal ist
nicht unbedingt jetzt der Engine, der dafür bekannt
ist, für große Open-World-Szenarien.
Generell
die Map ist auch viel kleiner und alles.
Das macht einen Riesenunfall.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen,
Leute, man kann das nicht so genau
vergleichen. Ich meine,
Pupke bzw. Bluehole benutzt
halt so, naja, wahrscheinlich
haben sie ein paar Anpassungen dran oder was weiß ich,
was die da für einen Deal mit Epic Games haben.
Aber
Fortnite benutzt die Engine,
weil es der Hersteller, weil es
kommt vom gleichen Laden, ja.
Also warum sollte Epic
dafür was anderes, Epic Games was anderes
dafür verwenden? Das ist ihre hausinterne Engine,
die halt auch verkauft wird.
Hat anscheinend da relativ unfähige Leute
dran sitzen, wenn man sich die technischen
Sachen anguckt.
Ja, H1Z1, auch so ein schönes Beispiel
für Verkackt. Das war ursprünglich
von Sony.
Und überhaupt nicht Battle Royale.
Hahaha. Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass...
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass
Bluehole gerne als Butthole verarscht wird.
Ja, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Oh man.
Ich finde ich das... Ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich das jetzt lustig
finde.
Ähm, Arena of Faith,
genau, das gab's doch.
Crytek Mobile.
Ich finde das lustig, ne?
Ich, ich verliere keine Viewer.
Ich, ich hab hier Standbild Overwatch,
Game und Flame über irgendwelche Spiele auf.
Vielleicht soll ich
das immer so machen.
Max Flamestream.
Das wäre einfach, ne?
Kannst du das Uploaden auf YouTube
sparen? Kannst du mir das sparen, ja.
Hahaha.
Ähm, magst du, kennst du
Evolve Stage 2? Da kann ich nichts
zu sagen, aber zu Evolve hab ich
den passenden, gerade hier
zufälligerweise im Discord,
der dazu was sagen kann. Was sagst du denn
zu Evolve, wo wir grad dabei sind?
Ihr müsst wissen, der Eax hat Evolve
auch, äh, naja, kann man das
Pro nennen? Ne, da gab's kein Geld für, oder?
Ja,
wenn du 3000 Euro
Ja, Eax war Evolve Pro,
da habt ihr's. Was, was denkst du
von Evolve?
Ja, was soll man dazu denken?
Am Anfang war's,
ich sag mal, am Anfang hat's mir richtig gut gefallen,
das Game, weil es war, äh,
extremer Tryhard,
vier Leute gegen einen Monster und sowas,
und es war halt für die
Hunter extrem schwierig, äh, gegen
Monster zu gewinnen, und daran war eigentlich,
äh, ein ziemlich großer Reiz.
Fand ich persönlich, also. Meinst du,
meinst du, das Game ist gefällt, weil das, ähm,
du hast einfach gegen,
also mit vier Randoms hast du gegen gutes Monster
keine Chance gehabt. Okay. Vorbei.
Okay. Kannst nicht gewinnen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das halt auch für, für
Leute, die einfach jetzt spielen wollten,
ein bisschen nervig war.
Das hat auch... Das ist halt steißig, du musstest
dich darauf verlassen, dass dein Trapper zum Beispiel, äh,
den Dome richtig setzt, ne, das Monster
einfängt, aber nicht zeitgleich auch noch
out of position ist, sodass der nicht sofort
wieder stirbt, ne, weil wenn der gestorben ist,
dann war ja das Dome auch wieder weg.
Ich glaube, was auch ein bisschen das Problem bei Evolve
war, dass, ähm, von der
Idee her, das war
nicht schlecht.
Aber ich glaube,
das ist ein Game, was auch sehr schnell einen Reiz
verloren hat, weil es halt wirklich immer das gleiche
ist. Also da...
Also fand ich nicht. Fandst du nicht? Okay.
Ja, ne. Wie gesagt, ich hab's nicht groß gespielt.
Du weißt das besser. 1200 Stunden hab ich da eingepumpt.
Wie viel? 1200.
The fuck? Okay.
Ja. Dann hab ich nichts gesagt.
1177.
Es war auf jeden Fall schon geil. Also der Reiz war
auf jeden Fall da, äh, competitive zu spielen.
Casual-mäßig
würde ich eher sagen, da hast du
besser als Monster gespielt.
Okay.
Da musstest du dich einfach nicht auf deine Teammates verlassen.
Ich meine, das haben sie dann über die Zeit
haben sie das geändert, ne. Dann war die Balance
irgendwie total für den Arsch.
Wenn man das so sagen kann.
Ja. Okay.
Ja, und Stage 2, da konnte dann irgendwie
keine Ahnung, wo das dann free-to-play
geworden ist, dann ist... Ja, konntest du das
wegschmeißen, das Game. Dann konnte dann
jeder auf einmal das Monster einfangen und so.
Dann waren diese kompletten
Teamplay-Rollen komplett aufgeteilt.
Okay.
Ja, das war auch ein Game, was mit sehr viel Hype
gestartet ist, was ja auch eine gute
Idee war.
Es sah halt gut aus, ne.
Also so grafisch war es ja drop-notch und so.
Ich kann mich da nur noch
dunkel dran erinnern. Aber da gab's dann so
Situationen zum Beispiel, da gab's ja
das, ähm, das dritte
Monster, das war ja der Wraith, ne.
Der konnte sich ja unsichtbar machen und
ja, es gab tatsächlich Spieler, die hatten
nichts Besseres zum Scheißen, als eine halbe Stunde
sich zu verstecken.
Klingt spaßig. Die sind einfach, ja, die
sind einfach nur weggerannt und, äh,
damals konntest du ja dem Dome noch richtig gut
ausweichen, weil du hast jemanden gebraucht,
der das Monster erstmal, äh,
Jetzt mal für uns Noobs,
jetzt mal für uns Noobs, was ist
der Dome?
Das ist eine Arena-Kugel.
Die wirft man, die baut sich
dann über Zeit auf und dann ist das Monster
da drinnen gefahren.
Und dann kannst du's bashen. Genau, dann kannst
du's bashen oder es basht dich.
Okay.
Interessant. Ich hab, wie gesagt,
mich nie großartig mit Evolve beschäftigt.
Gut, dass wir das nochmal geklärt haben.
Im Chat,
im Chat gibt's Auffall. Hallo
Twizy, OP, Missy,
Gare, Tiger und
Bene1A2D.
Also eigentlich, ihr müsst wissen,
ich wollte jetzt schon seit wahrscheinlich einer
gefühlten Stunde Schluss machen, aber wir haben uns
jetzt eher dafür entschieden, wir flamen einfach nochmal alle
Games, die es aktuell so gibt.
Weil wir grad dabei sind, so.
Gibt's noch Games, die wir flamen sollen?
Habt ihr Vorschläge?
Ach, ne.
Äh, das ist auch
ein Game, was voll in die Hose gegangen ist.
Anders bei Rainbow Six?
Aber da haben sie's verkackt, weil, du,
die haben ja den Casuals gar nichts angeboten.
Es gab wohl auch krasses Pay-to-Win,
hab ich das richtig in Erinnerung?
Nee, bei Evolve hattest du nicht.
War das, ja, mit Stage 2,
war da nicht irgendwas? Ich hab im Hinterkopf
irgendwie klingelt bei mir
da so Pay-to-Win, wenn ich an Evolve denke.
Du konntest Helden kaufen, ja.
Monsterhelden, die haben gekostet.
Aber, die Sache ist,
die von Anfang bis Ende
konntest du eigentlich eine Meta durchspielen.
Von Anfang bis Ende.
Und das war auch
die effektivste Meta. Also, so
Helden wie zum Beispiel, sagen wir mal, Trapper Crow,
der konnte zum Beispiel
so ein
Falken oder, was weiß ich, eine Fledermaus
schicken, damit konntest du dann das Monster
durch Wände sehen.
Okay.
Ähm.
Hat man es gebraucht? Eigentlich nicht.
Also, meinst du, war gar nicht so
übertrieben, Pay-to-Win?
Nee. Also, du hast mit den Standardhelden
gewonnen gehabt und das war auch so
auf dem Turnier so.
Hat, äh, ein Dings, Team YP
hat da mit Standardhelden gezockt,
die haben ein perfektes Position gehabt.
Team YP. Ich find das immer noch so geil,
dass man das so umschreiben muss.
Warum darf man das eigentlich nicht sagen?
Darf man doch sagen, oder?
Weiß ich nicht. Ist ja, also, mir kann's
egal sein. Du streamst ja nicht, ich, ne?
Ich, ich glaub, man darf schon
Team Youporn sagen, das ist schon okay.
Solange man nix zeigt.
Ja, falls ihr's nicht wusstet,
Youporn hat ein E-Sport, äh,
ist, ist auch quasi
ein E-Sport-Orga mit, ich weiß nicht,
ob sie überhaupt noch Teams aktuell haben,
aber zumindest haben sie das mal probiert.
Also, Overwatch haben sie, glaub ich, rausgeschmissen.
Oh.
Ja, gut.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Die haben damals das Turnier gewonnen und zwar
passt schon leicht, kann man sagen.
Die haben Standardhelden
gespielt, die hatten perfektes Positioning
und alles und
da konntest du ja wenig machen. Also, du hast keinen
DEC-Helden gebraucht, letzten Endes.
Okay. Ähm,
TwizyOP,
was, was meinst du, was soll ich oben lesen?
Ah!
Ähm,
TwizyOP sagt,
World of Warcraft 2-Spieler hab ich echt null Bock mehr.
Damals schon
Todesgesuchtet, möchte gerne mal wieder so was
Schönes wie Battlefield 3-Setting, das ist
Afghanistan, das in Afghanistan-Spiel wäre
perfekt für Bad Company, äh, 3.
Äh, ja, wird's wahrscheinlich ja auch.
Also, wenn man der Sache glaubt.
So, Kalter Krieg und Afghanistan,
sowas, ist ja angeblich Battle, ist Bad Company
3-Setting. Ähm,
weiß man nicht. Aber auf World of Warcraft 2-Spiele,
ehrlich gesagt, hab ich persönlich auch
keinen Bock. Das ist eines der
overuseden,
oh, jetzt machen wir ein geiles deutsches Wort drauf,
eine der overusedesten
Szenarien, die es überhaupt
gibt, im Shooter-Bereich.
Es braucht eigentlich, eigentlich braucht die Welt
wirklich keine World of Warcraft 2-Spiele
mehr. Man hat's jetzt auch an, an dem
neuen Call of Duty gesehen, ähm,
ein Szenario, das sag ich ja seit Jahren
schon, aber alle flippen dann immer wieder aus,
wenn da ein geiles Szenario kommt. Ich lass mich da
manchmal ein bisschen mitreißen. Ähm,
ein Szenario alleine
macht kein gutes Game aus.
Äh, haha,
For Honor! Hör mal auf.
Da müssen wir nicht von anfangen jetzt.
For Honor. Haha,
lol.
P2P-Server. Wenn man das, wenn man das überhaupt mal
spielen konnte, ne, wenn man nicht die ganze Zeit
auf Server geflogen ist. Server,
in Anführungszeichen. For Honor. Ach, Gott.
Auch ein
Game, super Ansatz,
auch eigentlich
super Umsetzung.
Man kann ja nicht sagen, dass das schlecht
gemacht gewesen wäre oder so.
Aber Fail in der
Kerndisziplin bei einem Multiplayer-Spiel.
Wenn man sich Cheater und Leg-Switcher an den ersten
Tagen schon angeguckt hat, war schon einfach,
das war nicht mal schön.
So. Nicht so erfolgreich
bisher heute. Ja, wir sind eigentlich schon fertig.
Äh, come on. Wir sind
eigentlich schon fertig. Ich laber bloß seit einer Stunde,
wie kacke ich alle Games finde.
Um es mal so zusammenzufassen.
So, ich guck jetzt
nochmal kurz in die Follower-Liste
rein. Wen haben wir denn da? Ich seh leider
nicht mehr alle.
Destroix, Dropus,
Lyrics,
Mr. Samu, lol.
Mr. Lenox, Zero,
Samu,
Freebo,
Geisterkürbis, Tommy,
KPNR, Robinson.
Mehr seh ich leider nicht mehr.
Ich seh jetzt leider bloß die letzten paar bis zu
27 Minuten.
So. Ich guck jetzt mal kurz rein,
ob ich irgendwas überlesen hab. Und dann machen wir
Schluss.
Das ist schön für dich, Mr. Samu.
Ich hoffe, du hast was von.
Die Welt kauft doch das neue
Code fast doppelt so oft wie das letzte Code.
Wundert mich auch nicht.
Ja, wir brauchen dazu nix sagen, ne?
Nö. Wir haben's ja sogar gespielt.
Wir haben's gespielt. Wir haben's auch
gekauft und gespielt.
Auf dem PC mittlerweile unspielbar.
Dank.
Wir nennen's mal Cheater, nicht Hacker. Hacker ist das
falsche Wort für. Hacker
hat ja so den Anschein, als hätten die irgendwas geleistet.
Als hätten die irgendwas gehackt.
Die haben ja nix gehackt. Jemand anderes hat's für sie
gehackt. Und sie haben sich den Scheiß gekauft oder
runtergeladen. Mit zig Viren
wahrscheinlich noch.
Ja, das wollen wir natürlich
hoffen, dass das so ist.
Ich hoffe, denen haben sie
alle ihre Bitcoins geklaut.
Falls sie welche hatten.
Will mir nicht einer mal ne Bitcoin
spenden?
Die sind gerade so günstig im Wechselkurs.
Das letzte Mal, wo ich
geguckt hab, ne? Ich glaub, war Bitcoin
irgendwie bei 17k.
Krasser Scheiß.
Moin, Sebastian.
Marcelinchen.
Leute, wo kommt ihr eigentlich alle her jetzt?
Wenn du das grad in Labo stellst, das kriegst du in der Führung an.
Ich bin grad übelst am Labern.
In welchen Grafikeinstellung
spielst du, Max? Alles low.
Ja, Twizy, OP. Ich hoffe auch nicht, dass
Bad Company 3 erstes Jahr
draufkommt, aber es deutet darauf hin.
Destiny 2. Destiny 2
haben wir schon besprochen.
Kurz zumindest.
Ja, das ist...
Das ist Ubisoft-Taktik oder ich weiß gar nicht,
welches Studio For Honor entwickelt hat.
Ich versteh's auch nicht. Wie kann man ein Multiplayer-Spiel
machen? Sowas wie For Honor?
Also ein Spiel, was
direkt quasi...
Du machst eine Aktion und brauchst eine Response
darauf. Wie kannst du das
P2P machen? Und am besten
noch die Leute, die den Scheiß verteidigt haben.
Ich hab ja ein Video dazu gemacht, wo ich mich drüber ausgelassen
hab,
wie kacke
das Spiel läuft und was es in der Beta
für Probleme gibt. Da kamen wieder die üblichen Leute
mit. Ach, Max, das ist doch nur eine Beta.
Bla, bla, bla. Eine Beta, die vier Wochen
vor Release kommt, ist keine Beta unter dem Sinn,
was man eigentlich früher als Beta verstanden.
hat. Und so nach dem Motto, ja,
P2P-Hosting ist super, das
reduziert die Latenzzeiten.
Haha. Was theoretisch
so sein mag, aber praktisch dazu führt,
dass der Client komplette Kontrolle über das hat, was
passiert. Und das ist beim Multiplayer-Spielen
immer, egal wo,
immer scheiße.
Der Client kann dem Server was sagen, aber
der Server muss letztendlich entscheiden, was Sache ist.
Sonst öffnest du ja
Cheaten und Lag-Switchen mit Geschiss, Tür
und Tor.
Und man hat's bei For Honor gesehen.
Was sagst du zu Red Dead Redemption 2?
Finde ich gut, dass es kommt. Kann ich
nichts zu sagen. Was hältst du
von The Forest? Äh...
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, war irgendwie ein
Survival-Game, ne?
Mass Effect, Antromeda, nicht gespielt.
Dass es im Wald ist,
hätte ich mir auch noch denken können.
Ähm...
Eigentlich war das voll blöd jetzt gerade.
Norman Sky,
ne, darf... Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Fangen wir jetzt nicht von an.
Norman Sky.
Hast du eigentlich mitbekommen, dass du in einigen
Overwatch-Montagen zu sehen bist? Was, in einigen?
Ich kenn bloß dieses eine
Win and Fail, wo
mein 5K
Reinhard Hammer auf Numbani
dabei war.
Jonny, Bug, Slush.
Wenn's da noch mehr gibt, schick mal
bitte Links. Würde mich interessieren, wo ich
noch gelandet bin.
Mach doch mal ne Runde Battlefield 3,
ist und bleibt mein Lieblingsspiel. Hab ich letztes
Wochenende, glaub ich, erst gemacht.
Gute Nacht, Alex.
Hättest du zurzeit Bock
auf ein MMO? Ja, ich spiel ab und zu mit dem
Friseur-Pleck, der ist halt online.
Moin, Levi. Beziehungsweise
eigentlich gute Nacht.
Stream. Stream ist quasi
schon seit ner Stunde am
sich beenden.
Sebastian kommt von YouTube, nice.
Wie sehen gerade eigentlich Bad Company 2
Server auf dem PC aus?
Ähm, das letzte Mal, wo ich reingeguckt hab, gab's...
Es war spielbar.
Weil, es schwimmt nicht in Servern, ja.
Was ist spielbar?
Was? Bad Company 2 ist down?
Ernsthaft?
Wirklich?
Also ich hab das...
Das ist doch gar nicht so lang her, wo wir das sogar
on Stream gespielt haben.
Ah, zum Glück kam aber Bad Company 2 noch Server
selbst hosten.
Ja, aber wenn das down ist, dann gibt's ja gar
nix mehr, oder wie?
Weiß nicht.
Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass das down ist.
Muss ich mal später ausprobieren.
Beziehungsweise...
Beziehungsweise morgen.
Ein Spiel zu playen, wie wär's mit Ark?
Kann ich nix zu sagen, hab ich nicht gespielt.
Weiß nur, dass die Entwickler sehr
enthusiastisch auf der Gamescom waren.
Bei Ark.
Also mega enthusiastisch.
Das waren halt nicht die üblichen Marketingtypen, die halt
fake happy und fake excited sind.
Das waren halt wirklich Entwickler.
Ich glaub, das war auch...
Ist auch ein relativ kleiner Laden.
Die waren wirklich begeistert von dem Game.
Ich nicht.
Ich mag keine Survival-Games, aber die haben es geschafft, dass ich mir sogar das Game angeschaut habe, obwohl ich diese Sorte, Genre und so überhaupt nicht mag.
Wie wär's mit einem Age of Empires 2 Match?
Alter.
Wie lange ich das nicht gespielt hab?
Nein, ist nicht down Zocker gerade.
Also, Bad Company 2 geht noch.
Ich dachte schon, ey.
Puh, wie flur haben wir ein Ei.
23 und schon 34.
Kann das sein, dass ich vor einer Stunde gesagt hab,
ich mach jetzt aus?
Glaub schon.
Gibt ein Remake.
Gibt ein HD-Remake von Age of Empires 2, ich weiß.
Ist aber im Prinzip immer noch das gleiche Game.
Ja, mit denselben Fehlern wie damals.
Ich kann mich...
Ich hab gerne Teutonen gespielt.
Da konntest du dich verkämpfen mit Türmen.
Erinnerst du dich daran, wenn du mal, sagen wir mal, 200 Einheiten im Spiel hattest, wie das dann geleckt hat?
Oh, nee.
Weiß ich nochmal nicht.
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Ich weiß nur nicht, dass ich mich schön mit Türmen verkämpft hab als Teutone.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Age of Empires 3 hat mir viel besser gefallen.
Counter-Strike.
Nein, nein, wir spielen jetzt auch kein CS.
So, Leute.
Wen hosten wir denn jetzt?
Wer wird jetzt gehostet?
Eax, willst du nicht noch ein bisschen auf der Watch streamen?
Da könnt ich dich hosten.
Nein, nein, ich weiß nicht wirklich ernst gemeint.
Wen hosten wir denn jetzt?
Wen haben wir denn hier?
Habt ihr einen Vorschlag, wen ich hosten könnte, Leute?
Habt ihr irgendwie Lieblings-Streamer, vielleicht, äh, noch kleiner als ich?
Na, dann schlägt doch einer hier der Eiskräuter.
Sylvanas.
Wer ist das?
Das ist, das ist ein Charakter aus WoW.
Ich glaub, das ist ein Grill-Streamer.
Was, Korea?
Grill-Streamer.
Ach, ich hab Korea verstanden.
Ein Grill-Streamer.
Sylvanas-SE2.
Hab ich noch nie geguckt, weiß ich nicht.
Ich würd gerne irgendjemand hosten, den ich zumindest selbst schon mal wusste.
Also, wo er bisher wusste, dass...
... dass er streamt und was er streamt und wie er das so streamt und so.
Ja, die kannst du schon hosten.
Kannst du die hosten?
Kennst...
Okay, hast schon mal geguckt, dann hosten wir die jetzt.
Ja, hab den zuguck, ich mach.
Du musst jetzt mal reingucken.
Practice, practice.
Was spielst du?
Tracer.
Platin Tracer Overwatch Ranked.
Okay, jawoll, die hosten wir jetzt. Easy.
Vergiss dein Mikkei-Thread-Message nicht, ne?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das mit Threads funktioniert.
Weißt du, ich hab von Twitch eigentlich gar keine Ahnung.
Ja, eigentlich musst du ja nur hosten und du sagst im Chat hier ne Thread-Message.
Ach, Quatsch.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Also, Leute.
Ich geh jetzt pennen.
Wir sehen uns morgen in einem neuen Video auf YouTube, vielleicht auch im Stream.
Mal gucken, was wir dann streamen.
Ähm...
Ich wollte noch To The Moon 2 spielen, fällt mir auf.
Das neue, was es da gibt.
Aber das kann ich nicht on stream machen.
Da muss...
Da heul ich euch hier einen vor.
Ähm...
Eiskräuter, erwähne mich.
Ja, ist klar.
Ich mach jetzt einfach Ray Channel erwähnt Eiskräuter.
Lol.
Ähm...
Ja.
Leute.
Also.
Machen wir Schluss.
Wir sehen uns dann morgen.
Tschüss.
Okay.
Fertig.
Hm...
Ich seh ein Grill-Streamer...